Die Hinrunde ist gespielt. Die Teams sind auf dem Weg in die Winterpause. Wir verabschieden uns in ca. 90 Minuten plus Verlängerung auch dahin. Vorher gibt's hier aber unser Hinrundenfazit. Viel Spaß! Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Profis zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das an's Turno. Markus Kort aus dem Gebühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, ein letztes und ein 18. Mal dieses Intro in diesem Jahr. Willkommen zur letzten Folge der Rasenfunk Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer in diesem Jahr, in 2025. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich darf in wiederkehrender Freundschaft nach Freitagabend meinen Kollegen Marc Schwitzki an meiner Seite begrüßen. Hallo Marc.
Das sind wir auch. Das sind wir auch. Jörn, erstmal vielen Dank für deine Einschätzung von Nahe dran. Das ist wirklich ein Komplettunfall, Eva. Das ist wirklich ein Komplettunfall. Und es zeigt mal wieder, wie doof Traditionsvereine oft sind und wie oft sie sich selbst das Bein stellen. Also kannst du dir solche Szenen, wo es ja auch immer nur irgendwo um Egos geht, jetzt bei Eva's Becken vorstellen?
Marc, du hast…
Ja, okay. Ja, okay. Point taken. Aber davon mal abgesehen. Das ist nämlich genau der Punkt, mit dem ich mich auch länger über Jörn mal unterhalten habe. Es passt einfach nicht zusammen zu sagen, das ist eine strategische Entscheidung. Und wir machen das übrigens zwei Spieltage vor Winterpause. Was? Also wenn ich um das Verhältnis von Bajamović zu sowohl Eichner als auch der Mannschaft weiß, dann mache ich das doch im Winter. Und vor allen Dingen nicht dann, wenn sich danach ja alle auch nach dem Training vor die Kameras stellen können. Also wenn man das im Winter macht, dann wird ja nicht Christian Eichner bei, weiß ich nicht, beim SWR anrufen und sagen, ich würde übrigens mal Stellung beziehen, sondern die standen ja dann beim Training und dann kommt dieses Statement 2 raus. Das ist ja maximal unglücklich. Und das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Dazu kommt, was man so lesen konnte, Bayamovic soll ja schon einfach sehr viel mit Kritik aufgefallen sein gegenüber den Vereinsverantwortlichen. So, und das Ding ist, vielleicht hat er das ja wirklich in der Art und Weise gemacht, die nicht in Ordnung ist, die respektlos ist, die aufbrausend ist, die nicht dazu dient, dass man danach konstruktiv weiterarbeiten kann. Das okay. Aber inhaltlich hat er ja einen Punkt mit dem, was ich vor Jörns Sprachnachricht gesagt habe. Also dieser Kader wird doch jedes Jahr schlechter und man erkennt doch, ich weiß beim KSC überhaupt nicht, was die sportliche Identität sein soll. Außer, ja, wir entwickeln halt ein paar Eigengewächse, wobei das ist jetzt nur auch nicht ganz speziell. Also welchen Fußball möchte der KSC spielen und welches Spielertypen kauft er dafür langfristig ein? Keine Ahnung. Weiß ich seit Jahren nicht. Und dass man da als Trainerteam vielleicht sagt, Leute, also wir würden uns gerne das schon mal anders vorstellen, weil wir hier seit Jahren gute Arbeit leisten. Ich war, glaube ich, acht Jahre im Verein oder so.
Ich glaube, es sind sogar neun.
Das kann ich schon grundsätzlich verstehen. Ohne alle Details zu kennen, sieht das einfach richtig schlecht aus. Mario Eggimann macht bis dahin keine gute Figur, wie ich finde. Das begann schon im Sommer, als er bewusst gesagt hat, wir setzen uns jetzt mal einfach kein Saisonziel, weil in der 2. Liga weißt du ja eh nicht, wo du rauskommst. Das ist für mich immer eine Bankrotterklärung, weil du dich damit ja auch nicht angreifbar machen möchtest. Weil dann kannst du ja am Ende der Saison sagen, haben wir uns schon ungefähr so vorgestellt.
Wenn ich kurz einhaken darf, aber gleichzeitig im April sagen, ja, wir haben ja jetzt schon zwei Punkte weniger als in der Saison davor. Oder so. Na, der, glaube ich. Und das war kurz nach Ans antritt. Also der Mann ist ja auch noch nicht so lange da.
Und dann wird ein, also, wann hatte der KSC zuletzt so einen verdienten Trainer wie mit Christian Eichner? Davor waren es so Leute wie Alois Schwarz und Thomas Orwald, die da rumgetanzt sind. Und sagen wir mal, Christian Eichner sagt wirklich zum Ende der Saison, Freunde, das war's an der Stelle. Was ich komplett nachvollziehen könnte, ich glaube, er muss das mittlerweile fast machen, um seine eigene Karriere so ein bisschen zu schützen. Dann bin ich, dann wäre ich ja sehr gespannt, wer sich da als Nächstes hinsetzt und sich mit dieser Vereinsführung auseinandersetzen darf. Und das letztendlich hat das eben, weil das mitten in der Saison passiert, unmittelbare sportliche Konsequenzen. Jetzt hat man gegen Bochum gut ausgesehen oder zumindest verbessert, willensstark ist man aufgetreten. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das eine Mannschaft, die ohnehin zu letzt wenig Punkte geholt hat, jetzt keinen Push für die Rückrunde gibt. Und dann sind es plötzlich doch nur ein paar Punkte, nämlich genau 5 auf Platz 16, hat eine Mannschaft schon mal verspielt in der Rückrunde.
Ich glaube, man hat auch mit die, die schlecht, also die zweitschlechteste, lass mich mal kurz gucken, die drittschlechteste Defensive der Liga.
Und oftmals finden sie sich am Ende, zu den Teams kommen wir noch, die Teams werden der schlechtesten Defensive, auch meistens ganz unten wieder.
Ja, und vor allem diese untere Tabellenhälfte, du weißt gar nicht, wo du da anfangen sollst mit, ehrlich gesagt, als untere Tabellenhälfte punktetechnisch zu frameen. Also mir fällt es auf jeden Fall super schwer, sobald es mal wieder so eng zusammen ist. Und da musst du halt einfach auch ganz klar sagen, wird ein Torverhältnis die Rolle spielen? Und das macht natürlich was mit dem Kopf. Du hast dann fast zweimal hintereinander gegen Bielefeld, gegen Paderborn die vier Gegentore bekommen. Das darf dir so eigentlich nicht passieren, gleichzeitig finde ich, aber ich glaube, du hast es eben schon mal ganz kurz angesprochen, als der letzte Satz, den ich dazu sagen würde. Du siehst ja, dass diese Mannschaft auch im Zwieschall Zwiespalt ist zwischen, wir wollen ja nicht gegen unseren Trainer spielen, also es ist immer so ein bisschen Küchenpsychologie, das ist mir bewusst, aber wir sind ja fein mit unserem Trainer, aber eigentlich haben wir gar keinen Bock unter dieser Vereinsführung, mit den Aussagen, die die Vereinsführung trifft, mit der Kommunikation, wie sie uns behandelt. Unter den Voraussetzungen wollen wir eigentlich auch so nicht weitermachen. Und das hast du ja fast, diese Übereinanderstellung mit dem Paderborn spielen und mit dem Buchen spielen. Da hast du das ja eigentlich gemerkt. Und das finde ich so krass. Und da musst du also gerade in der Winterpause meiner Meinung nach mental auch richtig nacharbeiten.
Ja, gefühlt müssen die einen Blutpakt schließen, Christian Eichner und seine Mannschaft und sagen, wisst ihr was, wir wollen ja alle mit erhobenen Hauptes aus der Saison ausgehen. Wir machen das jetzt für uns. Und am Ende der Saison drücken wir uns nochmal ganz fest. Und dann geht jeder seine Wege. Weil dieser Kader wird ja auch, glaube ich, dann ein Stück weit auseinanderfallen. Gewisse Spieler wie Marcel Franke, Sebastian Jung, Marwin Weinizeck, die werden alle nicht jünger. Es gibt, finde ich, keinen gesunden Mittelbau in dem Kader. Das riecht also, egal wie die Saison endet, auch nach totalem Umbruch im Sommer, inklusive neuem Trainer. Aber jetzt erstmal geht, also ganz ehrlich, ich finde der KSC, der muss das vielleicht noch nicht selber in den Mund nehmen. Aber für den KSC geht es in der Rückrunde nur um nicht das Mal.
Ne, geh ich tatsächlich mit. Wir sagen jetzt mal nicht, wo ich den KSC getippt habe. Also ich lag da, glaube ich, auch nicht komplett alleine mit. Du bist mal ganz still.
Ja, ich weiß doch.
Warte mal, doch, zwei. Also Thomas und ich hatten den KSC da oben. Bei den HörerInnen, lass es mich kurz gucken, das schließt sich hier leider immer, hatten 17%. Also auch da waren wir nicht ganz alleine. Aber wie schön, dass wir jetzt über einen Verein sprechen, bei dem es auch ganz ruhig war, neben dem Platz zu sitzen.
Ja, die drücken sich quasi, die klinken in die Hand.
Die Fortuna, die hat die Spielvereinigung Führt empfangen. Und die Fortuna kann vor der Winterpause den fünften Sieg in dieser Hinrunde einfahren und damit Führt auf dem direkten Abschiebsplatz überwintern lassen, während man selbst auf dem Relegationsplatz nach 17 Spieltagen landet. Und zwar den Relegationsplatz nach unten hin, nicht nach oben hin. Das hat man sich vor der Saison sicherlich anders vorgestellt. Cedric Itten und Florian Muslia, da haben wir ihnen wieder Sorgen in der 24. und 65. Minute für die Fortuna-Tore Noël Futtkeut. Der macht das kurz vor Ende durch einen Elfmeter, nochmal spannend am Ende. Da bleiben die drei Punkte in NRW. Auch hier sage ich einmal schon mal, da ging auch relativ viel Chaos rum. Da kriegen wir gleich auch noch eine Expertenstimme. Aber Marc, lass uns auch hier erst auf Sportliche gucken. Platz 16, 17 Punkte, 15 zu 27 Tore, 5 Siege, 2 Unentschieden, 10 Niederlagen. Man konnte jetzt nach 3 Niederlagen in Folge gegen Elbersberg, Schalke und Dresden zumindest mal wieder punkten gegen ein Team im direkten Abstiegskampf neben dem FCM. Also gegen den konnte man auch punkten. Aber ich sag mal so, wir haben eben schon mal gesagt, die Uwe Rösler, Markus Anfang, Patrick Sander-Tabelle, die sieht nicht so schön aus für die Fortuna.
Nee, es war auf jeden Fall nicht Liebe auf den ersten Kick in dem Fall, wie bei Patrick Sander und Magdeburg oder Rösler und Bochum. Das hat dann nicht sofort Klick gemacht an der Stelle zwischen Anfang und der Mannschaft. Ich glaube auch, weil Anfangsberichtende ja viele auch ein spezieller Typ ist. Und da muss man sich vielleicht ein bisschen dran gewöhnen. Deswegen ist es eigentlich, glaube ich, besser für Trainertypen wie ihn, wenn er im Sommer irgendwo übernehmen darf und ein paar Wochen mit der Mannschaft hat. So war es jetzt dieses Mal nicht. Ich glaube, das Spiel zeigt schon, dass die Fortuna nicht so tot ist wie von einigen bescheinigt. Denn man muss ja auch sagen, das Spiel davor gegen Elbersberg, das dürfen die auf keinen Fall verlieren. Das müssen die eigentlich sogar gewinnen. Also die verlieren das 0 zu 1 und keiner weiß wieso. Der Sieg jetzt geht in Ordnung. Natürlich muss man sich weiterhin große Sorgen um diesen gesamten Verein machen. Da gehen wir ja gleich drauf ein. Aber das Spiel hat schon gezeigt, die Mannschaft will schon noch. Ich glaube, die hätte auch dieses Spiel nicht so bestritten, wenn die jetzt schon gesagt hätten, was ist mit Markus Anfang? Den wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall behalten. Also ich glaube schon, dass das auch Markus Anfang vielleicht ein bisschen Luft geben könnte. Warten wir mal ab, was im Winter entschieden werden könnte, auch zu ihm. Ich glaube schon, dass Sven Müslind hat. Er hat ja seinen ersten Arbeitstag gezeigt. Der zögert nicht, den Trigger zu pullen. Letztendlich war es ein verdienter Sieg für Düsseldorf, den man angesehen hat. Die können schon immer noch Fußball spielen. Die haben vor allen Dingen einfach individuelle Qualität. Cedric Itten, den habe ich sogar als Torschützenkündig getippt vor der Saison, weil ich dachte, eigentlich hat der gesamtmannschaftliche Erfolg die Rechnung gemacht. Aber Cedric Itten fand ich ganz okay in der Hinrunde. Ich glaube, er war zwischenzeitlich sogar verletzt, aber er hat schon seine paar Buden gemacht. Ich finde, er ist eigentlich ein perfekter Zweitligastürmer. Muslia kann ein Unterschiedspieler sein. Ist es in dem Spiel ja auch, macht die Vorlage zum ersten Tor und trifft dann per direkter Ecke, ist natürlich Glück dabei, aber er ist auch ein Spieler, der sich das durchaus mal erlauben darf mit seinem rechten Fuß. Ich glaube, wenn Markus Anfang diese Truppe ein Stück weit stabilisiert bekommt und die letzten zwei Spiele haben den Anschein gemacht, dann erste Dinge im Ballbesitz entwickelt, weil das ist eigentlich die größte Stärke von Markus Anfang und da wird der Winter ihm vielleicht auch ein bisschen gut tun, dann glaube ich, dass sich Düsseldorf richtig unrüblich, aber am Ende erfolgreich in der Klasse halten wird und dann ist im Sommer eh der Kahlschlag geplant. Ja und es hängt alles davon ab, wie jetzt die nächsten Wochen ablaufen, wie Mislentad kurzfristig wirken will, ob er jetzt schon sagt, ich muss eine Duftmarke setzen und schon sieben eigene Spieler bringen, das muss man mal abwarten, aber ja, erst mal Luft geholt, aber die Rückrunde wird weiterhin kein Zuckerschrecken, ich glaube nicht, dass die sich noch irgendwie ins Tabellenmiddelfeld spielen.
Ja, das ist immer auch die Frage, wo man Tabellenmiddelfeld definiert, ehrlich gesagt.
Das muss man wirklich sagen, spätestens nach diesem Spieltag hat sich ja so ein bisschen auch wieder Platz abgespalten zwischen ich glaube Platz sieben oder sechs und sieben, so, weil da liegen jetzt irgendwie fünf Punkte dazwischen und ab da geht es schon mal wieder, wenn du nicht um den Aufstieg spielst in der Zeitliga, spielst du gegen den Abstieg.
Guck mal, das haben wir schon in der Clown hingekriegt. Ich muss halt einfach sagen, also man muss einfach sagen zwei Siege, sechs Niederlagen, also sie spielen ja auch noch nicht mal unentschieden unter Anfang. Das ist halt auch irgendwie, glaube ich, einfach ein Problem. Also ich glaube, es hat dir manchmal geholfen. Und ich würde dir in diesem Spiel, ich würde dir fast noch widersprechen, weil erstens super unnötig diesen Elfmeter zu kassieren hinten raus und dass man danach noch zittert, ist halt einfach ein Problem. Also ich meine, klar, Fjord hat gegen Hertha gezeigt, die können auf einmal da doch irgendwie, geben sie sich irgendwie nicht mehr komplett.
Ja, sogar im Franken derby gegen Nürnberg sind sie auch zurückgekommen.
Sie geben sich nicht mehr komplett geschlagen, aber trotzdem muss man ja einfach sagen, also Fortuna hat endlich mal Tore erzielt, Nummer 14 und 15 in dieser Saison. Also Cedric, Isaac, Ne, Ed, Bleh, Younes, Ednut, Talib, hat fast genauso viele Tore alleine geschossen, wie Fortuna Düsseldorf gesammelt hat.
Man muss ja eigentlich sagen, Ja, aber die haben sich teilweise auch wirklich so selten dämlich vom Tor angestellt. Das war, glaube ich, irgendwann auch wirklich eine Blockade.
Aber Marc, auch hier haben wir, du hast eben Sven Müssel in Tat schon angesprochen. Wir hatten Haus auf Karlsruhe. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir, weiß ich nicht, Haus auf Düsseldorf oder Fortuna ohne Fortuna sagen wollen. Ich weiß es nicht. Düsseldorf. Aber auch hier hatten wir Chaos und auch hier haben wir bei lieben Menschen nachgefragt. Und zwar dem Thorsten von Gebrabbelrot Weiß, einem Fortuna-Podcast. Den kennt ihr auch hoffentlich hier vom Hören, auch immer sehr aktiv im Forum unterwegs. Und er erklärt uns jetzt auch mal, was war denn eigentlich zuletzt bei der Fortuna-Los?
In knapp 30 Jahren Fandasein bei Fortuna Düsseldorf kann ich mich wirklich an wenig Halbserien erinnern, die so in die Binsen gegangen sind wie diese. Nach tatsächlich ja recht harmonischen dreieinhalb Jahren hat Fortuna ihre Chaoswurzeln irgendwie so ein bisschen wiederentdeckt. Daniel Tune weg, Klaus Alofs weg, Christian Weber weg, Markus Amfang da und vielleicht wieder weg, Sven Mislinter da. Was ist denn da eigentlich los? Die negative Dynamik der ganzen Halbserie, die ihr ja auch schon umfangreich besprochen habt, die hat jetzt am Ende die sportlich Verantwortlichen auch erfasst. Nach fünf Jahren ist Klaus Alofs als Sportvorstand beurlaubt worden. Im sportlichen Bereich galt er eigentlich als der Hauptverantwortliche für den innenhomogenen Kader, der auf dem Papier vielleicht durchaus Qualität verspricht, aber als Mannschaft so gar nicht funktioniert. Dazu kommt der komplett gefloppte Trainerwechsel von Daniel Tune zu Markus Amfang mit einem Punkteschnitt schlechter als der von Frank Kramer. Frank Kramer! Trotz leichter spielerischer Verbesserungen ist Anfang größtenteils nicht gelungen, die Verunsicherung zu lösen. Und dazu muss man ja sagen, hat er eigentlich als Krisenmanager in der Vergangenheit selten irgendwo überzeugt. Doch Alofs, der eben diese Entscheidung getroffen hatte, waren natürlich auch neben dem Sportkader und Trainer für den Bereich Kommunikation zuständig und da ging in den letzten 6 Monaten ebenfalls einiges schief. Angefangen von der sehr offensiven Aufstiegsansage, die nicht nur den Druck auf das Team unnötig erhöhte, sondern von der er hinterher ziemlich peinlich so tat, als sei diese in medial zugewiesen worden, wofür es eindeutige Gegenbeweise gibt, dass dem nicht so war. Dann kam der geplatzte Transfer des israelischen Stürmers schon weiß man, inklusive Shitstorm, zu dem man genauso schwieg wie zu den relativierenden Aussagen anfangs zu dem rassistischen Vorfall bei Dynamo Dresden gegen seinen eigenen Spieler. Das kam ebenfalls nicht sonderlich gut in der Fanszene an und sorgte auch ein bisschen für einen Bruch dort. Jetzt läuft Alos Vertrag eben im Sommer aus, sodass man im Winter vor dieser Entscheidung stand, den Kontrakt entweder zu verlängern oder eben nicht. Und nach all diesen Punkten war eine Verlängerung im Grunde– weder in der Öffentlichkeit zu verkaufen, noch fand sich im Aufsichtsrat dafür eine Mehrheit. Das hat natürlich auch Alos gespürt und Anfang Dezember hat er dann verkündet, er stände für eine Verlängerung nicht mehr zur Verfügung, wodurch er der Entscheidung gegen ihm im Grunde zuvorgekommen ist, was er übrigens auch selbst dann öffentlich hinterher eingeräumt hat. Sven Mislintat wurde also für 3 Jahre als Nachfolger verpflichtet, übrigens auch mit einem für die 3. Liga gültigen Vertrag. Seine erste Amtshandlung war die Entlassung von Christian Weber, letzten Montag. Das kam wenig überraschend, zum einen, weil Weber natürlich als rechte Hand von Alofs ebenfalls für den unausgegorenen Kader mitverantwortlich war, zum anderen aber auch, weil Mislintat aufgrund seiner Erfahrung in der Vergangenheit, vor allem in Stuttgart und Dortmund, sich vermutlich da potenzielle Machtkämpfe und Konfliktherde einfach sparen wollte. Bis auf weiteres wird er da erstmal jetzt beide Positionen ausfüllen. Tja, was ist jetzt zu erwarten? Eins ist klar, hätte Mislintat nicht zuletzt so ein Karriereknick gehabt, hätte man ihn sicherlich nicht als Fortuna Düsseldorf verpflichten können. Bei ARKS Amsterdam und Borussia Dortmund gab es zuletzt Probleme, beim BVB vor allem mit unklaren Verantwortlichkeiten. Doch genau so ein Problem sollte es hier in Düsseldorf eher nicht geben. Als Sportvorstand quatscht ihm im Grunde aus dem operativen Bereich niemand in seine Arbeit hinein. Und ansonsten muss er sich natürlich einmal pro Jahr bei den Mitgliedern und vor allem beim Aufsichtsrat rechtfertigen. Aber der hat ihn gerade installiert und ich würde deshalb sagen, das Konfliktpotenzial gerade da ist kurzfristig erst einmal sehr überschaubar, zumal sein erster Auftritt eigentlich auch bisher oder seine ersten Auftritte sehr positiv. Jenafragen hat er so einen durchwachsenen Rekord gerade aus den Zeiten in Stuttgart. Da muss man jetzt wirklich sehen, wie es weitergeht. Aktuell ist da alles offen, darf Anfang weitermachen, muss er gehen, da ist tatsächlich alles denkbar. Und dann wird er das Wintertransferfenster nutzen müssen, um das Team zu stabilisieren. Zwischen zwei bis vier Verpflichtungen erwartet man, Außenverteidigung, Zentrales Mittelfeld, Sturm. Vermutlich, die werden sitzen müssen, genau wie die Trainerfrage. Ich traue es ihm zu, aber da ist natürlich jetzt auch ordentlich Druck auf dem Kessel, trotz des heimsiegestes Wichtigen gegen Fürth. Ich glaube aber grundsätzlich, dass die Situation mehr Chance als Risiko darstellt. Zum einen kann man sich kaum vorstellen, dass es noch schlechter als diese Hinrunde laufen kann. Und zum anderen machte eben Mislin Tat einen durchaus reflektierten und auch sehr zielstrebigen Eindruck auf seiner Antrittspk. Mein Gefühl ist also positiv, dass wir mit ihm die Kurve kriegen. Aber wir Rheinländer sind ja immer positiv. Hoffen wäre das Beste. Langweilig dürfte es in Düsseldorf auch in der Rückrunde nicht werden. Ich wünsche euch allen frohe Festtage und machtet Jod. Ja.
Fantastisch. Thorsten, vielen lieben Dank. Es ist ein Kunststück, all das in dieser kurzen Zeit zusammenzufassen. Dir ist es gelungen, würde ich behaupten. Und uns bleibt dann, glaube ich, zu Fortuna gar nicht mehr so viel zu sagen, oder? Ich meine, es ist wirklich der klassische Satz, wir müssen uns abwarten.
Nee, hast du recht.
Also, die Glaskugel, also den Blick, den traue ich mir gar nicht zu.
Ich sehe da halt auch wie Thorsten oder wie du es auch gesagt hast, einiges mehr Ruhe drin, als eben Alkaalsruhe, mit dieser Entscheidung im Endeffekt.
Ja, weil jetzt die halt entschieden sind, genau. Es brodelt nicht so. Und sowohl Düsseldorf als auch Müssentad wissen, und die sind jeweils die letzte Chance für einander.
Ja, das ist schon klar. Aber ich fand es auch trotzdem gut. Ich check schon, warum man eben den Klaus-Alaus-Vertrauten sich dann von denen getrennt hat, weil ich glaube, den Schnitt brauchst du einfach. Ich fand es aber gut, dass er eben nicht direkt gesagt hat. Er kann erstmal nicht für Markus Anfangs Ausführungen auch gerade gegenüber Immanuel Juha, beziehungsweise wir haben das hier auch in der letzten Folge besprochen, dass du da als Trainer einfach eine Sorgweitspflicht, beziehungsweise einfach auch eine Solidaritätspflicht gegenüber deinen Spielern hast. Und das war es nicht. Aber ich glaube, es ist schon sehr vernünftig zu sagen, ne, dann setzen wir uns vielleicht mit Team, mit Trainer und Co. in einer Winterpause zusammen und dann gucken wir, ob das weitergehen kann und machen da jetzt nicht noch eine Kurzschlusshandlung draus. Und das fand ich schon sehr, sehr vernünftig, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, wie funktioniert jetzt die Überleitung zur Spielvereinigung Fürth? Ich glaube, so viel brauchen wir den Fürther nicht mehr zu sagen. Ich glaube, Michi hat das zuletzt auch ganz gut aufgearbeitet. Sie stehen auf Platz 17. 15 Punkte, 26 zu 44 Toren, vier Siege, drei Unentschieden, zehn Niederlagen. Seit sechs Spielen ohne Sieg, davor gab es den Sieg gegen Münster, aber auch unter Heiko Vogel läuft es nicht so richtig, obwohl man zumindest gegen Nürnberg und Hertha punkten konnte, auch nach Rückstand. Ja, ich glaube, gerade defensiv fliegen da die Probleme. Mit 44 Gegentoren stellt man die schlechteste Defensive der Liga. Und ich habe einfach mal nachgeguckt. Jan Regensburg, die hatten– und ich weiß, da haben wir letztes Jahr um die gleiche Zeit auch wirklich schon ganz, ganz groß mit der Warnklingel gemacht– die hatten zum gleichen Zeitpunkt 39 Gegentore im letzten Jahr. Die haben zwar auch, ich glaube, nur acht Tore geschossen. Da führt ein paar mehr, das muss man ihnen schon lassen. Ich muss sagen, laut XG-Tabelle ist man sogar Letzter mit 16 Punkten. Also trotz einem Punkt mehr, ein Tabellenplatz weiter unten. Ja, ich glaube, Marc, es ist einfach– man muss einfach sagen, die Probleme, die wir vor der Saison schon diagnostiziert haben, sie sind durchaus eingetreten.
Ja, auch ein Verein im Umbruch, das muss man ja auch sagen. Ich glaube, das ist dann die Überleitung zur Düsseldorf, dass es da auch größer brennt als jetzt nur in der ersten Mannschaft, sondern dass du da Strukturprobleme hast. Wir erinnern uns an diesen offenen Brief, der einmal alles angesprochen hat im Verein gefühlt. Diese Defensive ist wirklich– das ist gespenstisch. Die haben ein einziges Mal zu Null gespielt. Und hier beim Spiel gegen Düsseldorf, beim 1-0 überhaupt nicht am Mann. Beim 2-0 verpennt man die Ecke, es sind einfache Dinge. Heiko Vogel sagt selbst, dass es die Basis sei, auch mal zu Null zu spielen, weil man halt nicht immer von der Offensive verlangt kann, zwei Tore oder mehr zu erzielen. Und das ist zuletzt gegen Hertha zumindest oder gegen Nürnberg noch gelungen. Aber dann gewinnst du die Spiele nicht mal, obwohl du so viele Tore schießt. Der Trainerwechsel war dringend notwendig. Es gab mutmachende Leistungen, wie ich finde, im Derby, wie auch gegen Hertha. Zumindest in der zweiten Halbzeit, in der ersten fand ich Föhrt gegen Hertha wirklich erschreckend schlecht. Und dahingehend tut natürlich diese Niederlage gegen Düsseldorf im direkten Duell so sehr weh, weil man sich natürlich gewünscht hätte, wahrscheinlich mindestens auch da einen Punkt zu holen, um dann zumindest diese drei Spiele vom Trainer, also dass der da aus einer relativ wenig angekratzten Bilanz dann in den Winter geht, dass es so nicht gekommen. Und die Aufgaben für den Winter sind klar. Defensive werden in den Griff bekommen, denn Offensiv mit Futtkoi, Hirgota, Klaus, Green, das ist individuell immer noch überdurchschnittlich, auch wenn es nicht jünger wird. Das ist so schwierig. Ich glaube schon, dass Firt in der Liga bleiben kann, wenn sie die Defensive einigermaßen in den Griff bekommen, aber das ist halt das Größte, wenn der Liga. Und dementsprechend tue ich mich irre schwer, da zu sagen, wo es am Ende endet. Aber wie gesagt, mein subjektives Gefühl, mein subjektiver Erfahrungsschatz ist, die Teams, die die Defensive nicht in den Griff bekommen, die werden am Ende auch unten landen, weil das nun mal der Faktor ist, der über auch mal einen Punktgewinn entscheidet. Und ich sehe da immer noch mehr, nicht schwarz. Seit Heiko Vogel habe ich auch ein paar Grautöne drin, aber da muss im Winter schon was passieren. Und du hast es schon gesagt, Eva, Transfermarkt im Winter, der ist jetzt nicht nett. Ich frage mich auch so ein bisschen, wo sie ansetzen wollen, sagen sie, weil das Problem ist, zum Beispiel, die haben ein riesiges Torhüterproblem. Bis zu dem Torwartwechsel war Pelle Böwing der schlechteste Keeper der Liga, statistisch gesehen. Timo Schliegs Zahlen habe ich mir nicht angeguckt, weiß ich gerade nicht so genau. Die Innenverteidigung, na ja, mir fehlt es oft irgendwie auch auf der 6. Also Julien Green ist nun mal einfach ein Spielmacher, kein defensiver Ackerer. Also wir sind bei diesem Herzstück, was bei Paderborn und Co. stimmt. Da gucke ich halt ins Mittelfeld und sehe Dietz, der eigentlich Innenverteidiger ist, und Green, der eigentlich eher mehr Zehner als Sechser ist. Das passt für mich nicht zusammen. Also du hast viele Ansatzpunkte, aber wie gesagt, ich verweise auch da nochmal auf die letzte Ligaturfolge mit Michi Fischer, der das ja alles schon zu genüge und sehr gut wie immer ausgeführt hat.
Also der Safe-Percentage in der ganzen Saison bei Fjord liegt bei 55,2%.
Das ist so...
Also darüber drehst du mit 57,1%. Beste übrigens, ja, Thiago Ernst, beziehungsweise Beide Härter, mit 79,2%. Laut von FB-Rap.
Ja, das zeigt sich halt, ne? In dieser... Ich hab das ja auch nochmal angeguckt, ist es also in dem Fall die Optazahlen zu Tore verhindert. Bei den Torhütern jetzt exklusiv. Und da sind eigentlich ausschließlich Torhüter dabei aus der oberen Tabellenhälfte. Also es gibt da kaum einen Keeper aus der unteren, der jetzt sagt, der rettet den noch was. Unten hast du Boving von Fürth, Schreiber von Dresden, Ron-Torben Hoffmann von Braunschweig, Bernat ist dabei, der schlimmste, also der, der am meisten quasi die größte Diskrepanz zwischen Tabellenplatz der Mannschaft aufweist und seinem Wert hier ist Nauel Neu von Hannover, der bislang sogar eine negative Bilanz hat, also mehr Tore kassiert, als er eigentlich sollte. Also du siehst einfach in dieser Liga so ein paar einfache Wahrheiten, wie hab halt einen guten Torhüter, die entscheiden schon sehr viel.
Obwohl ich es sehr witzig finde, wenn man einfach auf Saves guckt, es führt einfach komplett der Mittelfeld mit 53, Timohan mit den meisten, 67, Schalke mit 27.
Das sind halt die totalen Zahlen. Die kriegen halt auch mehr aufs Tor und dann ist die prozentuale Zahl viel wichtiger.
Ja, ich glaube, also, übrigens einfach nur nochmal defensiv in den Griff kriegen. Weißt du noch, wie viele Gegentero Regensburg am Ende der letzten Saison hatte? 71. Aber…
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die sind noch in die 70er gerodigt.
Genau, aber auf nur 23 geschossene Tore. Also das hat Firdscher mal überquert, aber auch sehr amüsant eben im Gegenzug nochmal Ulm dazu zu sehen. Die hatten 36 zu 48 Tore. Nur Defensive bringt ja auch Leid. Ulm hatte, glaube ich, mit einer der besten Defensive in der Liga. Also verhältnismäßig.
Nicht ohne Grund sind auch die Defensivspieler fast mit Kolbe und Schrumpf und so. Die sind ja alle in der 2. Liga einfach gebiegen.
Naja. Und jetzt kommen wir vielleicht… Ich würde sagen, ich glaube, es reicht auch, was wir zu Fird gesagt haben. Wir kommen zu einer Partie, wo ein Team, die haben sich so ein bisschen rausgemausert da unten. Das ist der 1. FC Magdeburg. Die haben 3 zu 2 bei Kaiserslautern gewonnen und verabschieden sich eben mit einem Ausflusssieg in die Winterpause. Nach 49 Minuten steht es bereits 3 zu 0 für die Gäste. Artig in der 22. zu Kowski in der 35. und Neulenberger kurz nach Wiederaanpfiff. Legenden Grundstein für den Magdeburger Sieg. Kaiserslautern kann zwar innerhalb von vier Minuten doppelt mit Hans Lick und Ritter nach Elfmeter zurückschlagen. Reicht am Ende nicht mehr. Kaiserslautern, mit dem fangen wir kurz an. Platz 7, 27 Punkte, 29 zu 21 Tore, 8 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 6 Niederlagen. Eigentlich eine solide Saison. Ich glaube, die letzten Ergebnisse, die sind eben die, wo man jetzt zuletzt vielleicht auch aus FCK-Sicht so ein bisschen froh ist, dass jetzt Winterpause ist. Das 2-3-1-Heimsieg gegen Dresden dazwischen, aber eben auch Niederlagen gegen Braunschweig und Hertha, vor allem eben im Pokal. Das hat zwar nichts mit Liga zu tun, aber diese 6 Gegentore, die waren es, glaube ich, trotzdem nicht. Das furchtbare 0-0 auf der Alm, ich habe es eben schon gesagt. Und jetzt eben diese 2-3-Heim-Niederlage, wo man ehrlich gesagt einfach sagen muss, klar, hinten raus vielleicht noch was möglich, aber man verspielt oder gibt dieses Spiel einfach in den ersten 50 Minuten aus der Hand. Marc, was ist denn, ich meine, zu Kaiserslautern hatten wir ja auch gesagt, das ist auch irgendwie so eine Mannschaft, da weißt du irgendwie nie so zu 100 Prozent, auch weil eben die Erwartungen ja dadurch auch immer hinter sind. Was machst du denn mit dieser Halbserie? Mit dem FCK?
Tja, Thorsten Lieberknecht hat der Hinrunde vor dem Magdeburg-Spiel eine 3 gegeben als Note. Vielleicht ist es jetzt eher eine 3 Minus nach der Niederlage, zumal sie zu Hause waren, wer weiß. Aber ich habe ja glaube ich in der Prognose damals schon gesagt, dass ich Kaiserslautern ohne Wenn und Aber als Team der oberen Tabellenhälfte sehe in der 2. Liga, aber Aufstieg, da tue ich mich schwer und ich mache das schon ein Stück weit am Trainer fest. Es gab wenig Konstanz jetzt unter Thorsten Lieberknecht, wie ich finde. Vor allem die Defensive strauchelt immer wieder. Das hat doch dieses Spiel gezeigt. Also nach 50 Minuten bei 3-0 hinten liegen. Teilweise, also beim 3-0, da haben die einfach das Verteidigen verweigert. Also Neuenberger darf einfach machen. Das ist einfach kein zweitlicher Niveau. Die sind im Pokal gegen Hertha so derber auseinandergefallen. Das war wirklich krass. Das habe ich selten gesehen. Und mir fehlen irgendwie überall so ein paar Prozentpunkte vom Lieberknecht-Lautern. Lautern kommt selten ans Leistungsmaximum, wirkt im Spiel recht eindimensional. Ich glaube, dass Lieberknecht dieses Spiel über außen vorgibt, über diese starken Schienenspieler. Was dann in der Mitte aber über einen Ritter oder einen Sküthel, der ein fantastischer Transfer war, passiert, das wirkt für mich oft eher so zufällig, beziehungsweise das entscheiden die dann für sich. Und dementsprechend finde ich Mitball– da haben wir schon drüber geredet, haben viele Teams-Probleme– aber Mitball ist mir das dafür, dass man eigentlich auch gute Fußballer hat. Da ist auch ein Schah hinzunennen im Mittelfeld. Ist mir das zu wenig. Lauterhand ist eine der pressingsstärksten Mannschaften der Liga, aber fällt regelmäßig auseinander, wenn dieses hohe Pressing mal überspielt wird. Da ist dann nichts mehr übrig. Also diese Restverteidigung, diese Staffelung funktioniert oft nicht. Dann verteidigt man teilweise echt wie eine Schülermannschaft. Und deswegen, ich finde, das ist alles irgendwie solide. Es wird am Ende auch für die obere Tabellenhälfte reichen, allein aufgrund der individuellen Qualität. Pratayan wird noch genug Spiele haben, wo er sein Schädel in die Flanke gehalten bekommt. Aber es wird, glaube ich, zumindest nicht für mehr reichen. Und mir fehlt unter Lieberknecht irgendwie die Vision. Und ich glaube, hier kann man ja vielleicht mal FCK-Boss Hengen zitieren, der sagt, die Hinrunde war insgesamt absolut okay. Vieles ist mir schon zu negativ. Wir hatten auch viele Verletzte, das ist keine Auswähre, aber ganz so stark versetzt sind wir dann doch nicht. Wir sind okay unterwegs, aber nicht zufrieden. In der Rückrunde müssen wir gleich voll da sein, denn die ersten vier Spiele, das sind Hannover, Schalke, Elbersberg und Darmstadt. Und dementsprechend entscheidet sich da eigentlich schon, ob Lautern nochmal wirklich oben eingreift. Ich sage nein. Und ich glaube, dann schließt man die Saison irgendwo in der oberen Tabellenhälfte ab. Das wird langfristig nicht der Anspruch von Lautern sein. Ist für eine Saison, glaube ich, mal okay. Aber ich stelle mir eher Fragen über die Saison hinaus bei Lautern. Sagen wir mal so.
Ja, ich würde einfach nochmal Thomas Hengen hinterher zitieren. Tatsächlich, der hat nämlich auch gesagt, wir haben gesagt, dass wir vorne noch was tun möchten, ob uns das früh in der Winterpause gelingt werden. Wir sehen, wir haben aktuell drei verletzte Stürmer, Kenny Redondo, Mahir Emreli, Ivan Britein. Auch Daniel Hanslig war fünf, sechs Wochen verletzt. Das ist schon außergewöhnlich. Außergewöhnlich, würde ich ehrlich gesagt, also finde ich etwas zu kurz gedacht in der Liga, weil dafür hast du zu viele Vereine, die eben genau die Probleme eben auch hatten, dass da zentrale Spieler ausgefallen sind. Und klar, drei verletzte Stürmer ist dann schon speziell, aber ich möchte jetzt nicht gemein sein, aber sie sind für mich jetzt auch nicht die Harry Canes der zweiten Liga. So, ne? Also, dass sie jetzt vorher unglaublich irgendwie den Impact hatten. Klar, ist natürlich trotzdem schwierig, wenn du den Fußball spielen möchtest, das ist mir schon bewusst.
Also, Pritayen ist ja schon fast der Harry Canes der zweiten Liga, aber der tut tatsächlich weh bei allen anderen, würde ich auch sagen, ja okay.
Also, Redondo finde ich auch immer so ein, der kann ein richtig guter Zweitligaspieler sein, aber dafür bringt er es für mich ehrlich gesagt zu wenig auf dem Platz in zu vielen Spielen.
Was ich positiv bei Lieberknecht herausstellen wollen würde, ist schon ein Stück weit die Jugendförderung, dass man da aus der zweiten Mannschaft, aus der U19-Spieler heranführt, allen voran natürlich Mika Haas zu nennen, der sich auf der linken Schiene festgespielt hat, aber ja auch Leon Robinson, der mit jetzt 24 Jahren relativ spät erst den Sprung geschafft hat, aber er hat ihn geschafft, er ist durchaus wichtig für die Mannschaft. Ich glaube, dieser Owen Gips ist auch ein Spieler, der ist auch 19, der kommt aus der FCK-Jugend, also zumindest da traut sich lieber Knecht, den jungen Spielern, teilweise vor etwas etablierteren Spielern, das Vertrauen zu schenken. Also zum Beispiel hat sich Herr Haas auch gegen den Kleinhansel durchgesetzt und Co. Und das würde ich zumindest positiv nennen, und das hat ja wiederum eine Vision, ist aber eher auf individueller Ebene und nicht auf allgemein taktischer, kollektiver Ebene.
In unseren Saisonprognosentipps hatten drei Leute. Kaiserslautern und in den Top 3, das waren Lisa, Matthias und Moritz. Ich calle jetzt einfach mal out, ich bin einfach richtig gemein. Im Forum hatten 17, 15%, Entschuldigung, was 6 Leute waren. Also ja, ich gehe da sonst mit deiner Analyse mit und ich würde sagen, wir springen dann zum FCM. Die stehen auf Platz 15, haben sich eben vor der Winterpause noch über den Strich gerettet, was glaube ich alleine schon ein sehr, sehr großes Erreichen ist, auch wenn man eben punktgleich mit Platz 16 ist. 17 Punkte, 21 zu 29 Tore, 10 Siege. Oh ne, da habe ich was falsch aufgeschrieben. Ich war gerade so, 10 Siege, das kann ich sagen.
Das wäre beeindruckend.
Das ist der Vorführeffekt, wenn man 5 Siege, 2 Unentschieden, 10 Niederlagen, so wird der Schuh rund. Man muss noch dazu sagen, es war dieses Spiel am Samstag, es war der erste Jahrestag des Anschlags auf dem Magdeburger Weihnachtsmarkt. Und da hat vor allem Thorsten Lieberknecht nach der Partie nochmal, ich glaube, nach der Partie war es deutlich kritisiert, dass dieses Spiel zu dieser Ansetzung stattgefunden hat, weil er eben sagt, ehrlich gesagt, hätte man das ja auch irgendwo anders hinsetzen können, ob man das jetzt Samstag oder Sonntag spielt, hätte egal sein sollen. Ich glaube, es hat ja wieder, ja, DFB-Pläne machen ist kompliziert und DFL-Pläne, es ist mir bewusst, aber da dachte ich mir dann auch echt so, vielleicht wäre das irgendwie, ich meine, sie mussten letztes Jahr schon an dem, das wussten sie dann natürlich nicht, aber war es schon ein Spiel und es, aber die Magdeburger Fans da eben auch mit einer Choreo, also das war auch nochmal ein emotionaler Moment, um sich eben aus diesem Jahr zu verabschieden. Es ist das drittformstärkste Team der Liga momentan, mit drei Siegen, einen Unentschieden und einer Niederlage aus den letzten fünf Spielen. Darüber ja unter anderem der überraschende Sieg bei der Hertha, seit Patrick Sander Hauptverwandtlich ist. Neuter Spieltag, ne, again, wir sehen deinen Munster. Fünf Siege, zwei Unentschieden und drei Niederlagen. Und ich glaube, Marc, also du hattest sie ja auch, du hast diese Probleme vorhergesehen zu Beginn der Saison.
Du hast gesagt, ich habe, ja, ich war Nostradamus, ich habe nicht mit Patrick Sander gerechnet, bin ehrlich.
Ich meine, die Probleme waren ja da, aber man muss sagen, zuletzt, es ging ja, man hatte am Anfang schon okaye Ergebnisse, kann man glaube ich sagen, hatte dann zwischendurch wieder diese Niederlagen drin unter Sander jetzt speziell, hat sich aber zuletzt jetzt ja wieder sehr gut gefangen, gerade diese Siege eben auch gegen Nürnberg, diese Offensivkraft, die man eben wieder entwickelt hat. Das ist schon sehr bemerkenswert, was Patrick Sander da geschafft hat.
Absolut, wobei ich da tatsächlich das Gefühl habe, dass man zwei Namen nennen muss, Patrick Sander und sein Co-Trainer Pascal Ebold, denn Patrick Sander ist glaube ich der, der mit all seiner Erfahrung einfach diese ruhige Art, der gibt dieser Mannschaft Halt und soweit ich weiß, ist Pascal Ebold, der ist glaube ich 36 oder so, der sorgt wiederum für den taktischen Input. So und der coacht an der Seite auch viel mehr als Patrick Sander, der da oft eher stoisch sitzt. Und dieses Team funktioniert aber. Man hat zehn Punkte aus den letzten vier Spielen geholt, allesamt auch verdient, wie ich finde, da hat man sich nix erklaut. Magdeburg hat wieder zu sich und seine Identität gefunden, zurück zum mutigen Spiel, viele Dribblings, flacher Aufbau, nicht mehr so vertikal angelegt wie unter Markus Fiedler, der das ja schon ein bisschen direkter gestalten wollte, hatte ich das Gefühl, und womit die Mannschaft ja schon sehr gestrauchelt hat. Und wir erinnern uns an dieses Testspiel, was die gegen Braunschweig, ja ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das letztendlich Ergebnis war, aber es war katastrophal und das war ja in dieser Länderspielpause, wo es mit Fiedler, wo man eh diskutiert hatte, die Vereinsführung ihn nochmal gestärkt hatte, dann dieses Testspiel und dann hat man Fiedler doch entlassen. Da hat die Mannschaft sich ja schon sehr klar gegen den Trainer gestellt und diese Mannschaft muss dann aber auch liefern, wenn der Verein dann eine andere Lösung darstellt.
0 zu 6. Nur einmal kurz. 0 zu 6.
0 zu 6. Ja. Und das tut sie jetzt. Also ich finde das ganz spannend eigentlich, dass deine Mannschaft sagt, wir wollen eine Lösung A. Wirklich nicht, Leute. Dann gibt es Lösung B. Und dann muss das Team beweisen, dass es darunter besser funktioniert und das tun sie es. Zudem tut es ihnen extrem gut mit Zukowski. Weihnachtsbäckerei-Jokes bitte hier eingefügt.
Ein Platz, das wir schon gemacht haben.
Endlich einen treffsicheren Mittelschürmer haben. Ja, ich weiß. Aber jetzt sind wir noch näher an Weihnachten dran. Aber Zukowski, der jetzt endlich zurückgekehrt ist, der diese Cars-Lücke endlich mal so ein Stück weit stopfen kann. Dadurch spielt sich der FCM nicht mehr so ein Wolf bis zum Tor. Ja, Magdeburg, ey, das hat sich auch in dem Spiel gezeigt. Die kriegen zwei Gegentore. Das wird kein Defensivmonster mehr. Aber das ist ja auch okay. Sie finden ihr Heil im Sturm. Und da sind sie für jeden Gegner eine Gefahr. Und das muss man auch sagen. Ugoné, Heber, Lorik, Hyrulein, die fallen aktuell alle aus. Also die haben auch defensiv wirklich gerade massive Probleme. Deswegen die Außenverteidiger in einer Viererkette, waren jetzt Neulenberger und Herrscher. Also die haben bei anderen schon links und rechts außen gespielt. So. Und da bin ich einfach nur gespannt, mit welchem Flow kommen sie aus der Winterpause. Weil jetzt kommt der Cut fast ungelegen. Sie sind jetzt komplett drin. Spieler wie Ryan Creep und so sind jetzt richtig da. Bleibt man im Flow. Mit Dresden und Braunschweig hat man direkt sofort Kellerduelle. Wenn man die gewinnt und ein Stück, oder zumindest so vier Punkte oder so holt, dann glaube ich, dass das Magdeburg aus der Sache echt noch ziemlich souverän rauskommt.
Ja, und das wäre nach dem Saisonbeginn Lübe Grüße auch an Thomas aus unserem Eulster-Team. Ich glaube, der war am Anfang auch noch skeptisch, aber ich glaube, den hat es jetzt auch auf die positive Seite gezogen. Und da muss man einfach sagen, also das Magdeburg ist auch einfach ein schöner Standort. Ich meine, ich war ja Freitag auf dem Weg nach Berlin und dann hat er die A2. Sowieso ist immer mein Lieblingsding A2 runterfahren und dabei beobachten, wie quasi die verschiedenen Fußballmannschaften quasi wechseln. Und dann kommt ganz lange FCM. Also bis dann die Hertha anfängt, das ist immer sehr interessant. Ich würde sagen, damit machen wir das durch. Ich glaube, auch über den FCM haben wir viel gesprochen, immer wieder, weil es eben noch viel zu besprechen gab. Bevor wir jetzt weitermachen und in den Innsport gehen, haben wir Infos, Ankündigungen etc. zu machen. Also ihr wisst es, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, payroll- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich durch eure Unterstützung. Ihr ermöglicht eben auch, dass Marco und ich das jetzt hier übernehmen durften, dass wir jetzt eben dieses Allstar-Team auch haben. Das ist super. Stellvertretend geht der Dank in dieser Folge an Markus, Luki, Höhler, Fußballgott, The Okapi-Poster, 87, Rosophon, Philipp Börner und der Robert aus Berlin. Vielen, vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und ein kleiner Hinweis. Ab dem 1. Januar erhöhen sich die Gäste und Moderatorinnen und Moderatorinnen wie angekündigt erneut um 3%. Falls ihr denkt, Mensch, gute Sache, das will ich unterstützen, dann überlegt doch, ob ihr euren Betrag vielleicht auch um 3%, falls ihr schon unterstützt, erhöhen wollt oder sogar mehr, um vielleicht für Leute, die es nicht machen oder nicht machen können, da auch ein bisschen zu unterstützen. Darüber würden wir uns sehr freuen und ich kann sagen, ich werde das auch tun, denn ich bin auch Unterstützerin, weil ich immer finde, das ist eine gute Sache. Ja, und sonst kann man noch sagen, gestern, da ist das Hinrundenfazit, bzw. nicht Hinrundenfazit, sondern die aktuelle Bilanz, die Hinrunde in der Bundesliga der Männer, die ist ja noch nicht zu Ende gespielt, die ist erschienen mit Caro Kippa und Tobi Escher. Heute Abend bespricht Marc den Spieltag der Frauen, sonst erscheint rund um die Feiertage noch Schwerpunkte zu Bayern und Dortmund. Damit kommen wir, oder vor allem Marc, ehrlich gesagt, auf 173 Sendungen in diesem Jahr, insgesamt im Rasenfunk. Und wenn ihr das noch mal gehört habt, dann überlegt doch, wenn ihr irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der blöden Tante oder den blöden Onkel nicht schenken wollt, dann überlegt doch, ob ihr dem Rasenfunk eine Unterstützung schenkt. Dem guten Onkel und dem Max.
Und seinen helfenden Elfen, Marc und Eva.
Genau, überlegt das doch gerne darüber, würden wir uns sehr freuen. Und dann würde ich sagen, Marc, wir bewegen uns in den Endspurt rein. Vielleicht schaffen wir es jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller. Wir fangen an mit Kiel gegen Dresden. Kiel, kein Zuhause-Spiel gegen Aussteiger Dynamo Dresden. Drehend Vincent Vermeil, der sorgt für gute Laune im Gästeblock. Allerdings kann Phil Harris nach einer halben Stunde erst ausgleichen. Und dann Ivan Nikic. Das Spiel für die Störche Drehend. Wichtige, ganz, ganz wichtige drei Punkte für die Kieler Dresden. Die behalten über die Pause die rote Laterne. Kiel, die stehen auf Platz 11. 20 Punkte, 20 zu 22 Tore. Also wirklich irgendwie das komplette Mittelfeld. Kann man fast sagen. 5 Siege, 5 Unentschieden, 7 Niederlagen. Sie stehen im Pokal Viertelfinale. Das ist, glaube ich, die wichtigste Nachricht. Nach dem Sieg gegen den HSV im Pokal ist damit mit Hertha, das haben wir natürlich ein bisschen vergessen zu erwähnen, das einzige unterklassige Team, das eben in diesem Viertelfinale steht. Die treffen auf den VfB Stuttgart Anfang Februar 2026. Hertha spielt gegen Freiburg. Das sei noch chronistenpflichtig erwähnt. Nach vier sieglosen Spielen in der Liga hat man jetzt eben mal wieder gewinnen können. Marc, ich glaube, wir haben mit Kiel und Bochum zwei Absteiger, wo viele dachten– Absteiger, genau. Absteiger, so rum. Dankeschön. Wo man fast wirklich exemplarisch gesehen hat, womit Vereine, die entweder nach langer Zeit, aber längere Zeit aus der Bundesliga absteigen, als auch direkt wieder absteigen, für Probleme haben können. Wie würdest du denn sagen, hat Kiel sich bisher geschlagen?
Tja, da kann ich mal die Hosen runterlassen und sagen, ich glaube, ich habe getippt, dass Kiel hochgeht. Das ist richtig. Also habe auch ich da gewisse Dinge unterschätzt. Ich habe den Umbruch zwar anerkannt, dachte aber, dass Marcel Rapp das schneller sortiert bekommt und habe das dementsprechend wiederfahrend vielleicht selbst ein bisschen unterschätzt. Da steckt aber sehr viel im Kader drin, wie ich finde. Spielkultur, Körperlichkeit, Tempo, Tiefgang. Eigentlich muss das nur noch richtig ineinanderklicken, wie ich finde. Und vielleicht brauche es auch noch einen treffsichereren Mittelstürmer. Und das dauert aber vielleicht einfach länger, als man dachte. Ich finde, Kiel hat in dieser Saison wenig richtig schlechte Spiele abgeliefert bislang. Es hat bloß ganz oft irgendwie gefehlt. Und man war so ein bisschen bieder. Ich erinnere mich beispielsweise auch an das Spiel, jetzt ist das Jahr gar nicht lange her, gegen Hertha. Das war ein okayer Heimauftritt, aber halt auch kein guter. So, weil dafür irgendwie noch nicht die Automatismen drin waren. Und am Ende ist Hertha die cleverere Mannschaft, die dann halt das 1 zu 0 macht und gewinnt, obwohl das vielleicht gar nicht so hätte enden müssen. Zumal so Spieler wie Alexander Bernards dann noch nicht so ganz an ihr individuelles Hoch kommen. Jetzt gegen Dresden haben sie gewonnen. Ich fand auch insgesamt verdient. Es war mal wieder ein Patzer von Dresden, wovon dann in dem Fall Kiel profitiert hat. Beim 1 zu 1 Hermanns Ballverlust leitet das Tor ein. Wiederum finde ich, was man da sieht, Ballgewinner war Steven Skripski, der zwischenzeitlich raus war und der jetzt beim Spiel gegen Magdeburg diesen Distanzhammer hatte, jetzt die Vorlage, ich glaube, dass dieser Spieler, jemand, der so auf zweitige erfahren ist, der diese Tugenden auch so drin hat, der tut einer Mannschaft sehr gut, die ansonsten aus sehr vielen jungen Spielern und vor allen Dingen Deutschland und zweitig unerfahrenen Spielern besteht. Du hast ja sehr viele junge Spieler dazugewonnen, die teilweise, weiß nicht, zum Beispiel aus der Sowakei kamen, aus den Skandinavien. Das scheinbar muss ich noch finden. Ich sehe da immer wieder Ansätze, auch auf individueller Ebene, ob es ein Knutzen ist, ob es ein Terkelsen ist, ob es ein, ich glaube, David Zeck in der Innenverteidigung ist. Da ist schon viel da. Aber ja, ich glaube, also meine Tendenz wäre, die werden sich in der Rückrunde stabilisieren. Ich glaube, dass Kollege, na, wie heißt deren? Sportlicher Verantwortlicher, Feuer Nürnberg.
Ah ja. Oh Gott. Aha. Unangenehm. Warte kurz. Es ist live.
Man muss sich so viele Namen immer merken.
Ich muss ja auch einfach sagen, dass ich dauerhaft verwirrt bin, dass es zwei Benny Webers als Sportdirektorin gibt. Das wird für…
Ja, aber immerhin gibt es nicht mehr Christian Weber jetzt bei Düsseldorf. Da hat es ja ein bisschen Tag nach Rolf.
Olaf Rebbe ist es natürlich. Mein Gott.
Mein Gott, ja. Dankeschön. Olaf Rebbe hatte, glaube ich, vor ein, zwei Spieltagen noch angekündigt, dass man im Winter sich schon umschauen wird auf dem Transfermarkt. Ich will sagen, das war jetzt eine insgesamt eher ernüchternde Hinrunde, aber auch keine katastrophale. Soweit würde ich es überhaupt nicht stricken. Ich glaube, dass diese Mannschaft an Erfahrung und an Automatismen gewinnen wird. Ich glaube weiterhin an Marcel Rapp als Trainer. Die werden sich in der Rückrunde stabilisieren, vielleicht sogar noch in die obere Tabellenhilfe ein bisschen reinrutschen. Das könnte ich mir schon vorstellen. Und dann greifen sie als 26, 27 richtig an. Und ich glaube, da hat man auch das geeignete Umfeld für. Da wird keiner unruhig. Kiel weiß, woher sie kommen. Alles gut und weitermachen.
Um dich zu beruhigen, vier Leute hatten Kiel als Aufsteiger. Anna, Lisa, du und Max. Max sogar als auf Platz 1. Und die Hörerinnen bzw. die Führer, wie man das auch nennen kann. Schauen wir da auch nochmal ganz kurz. Auch bei 17 Prozent. Also ihr wart da nicht ganz alleine. Auch hier gibt es, es war 125-jähriges Jubiläum. Und passenderweise dazu, da sollen die Kieler, die sein neues Stadion bekommen. Alle, die schon mal in Kiel…
Endlich, das ist auch eine lange Nummer.
Ach, die schon mal in Kiel im Stadion waren, wissen, das ist vielleicht keine so schlechte Idee. Das soll eben neu gebaut werden, 22.000 Plätze, davon 12.000 Sitzplätze und 10.000 Stehplätze. Eben alle Stehplätze dieses Mal auf einer Tribüne kostet 75 Millionen Euro, wird finanziert aus einer Stadion-Gesellschaft, die bestehend ist aus Stadt, Land, Verein und Hauptsponsor. Starten soll das Ganze…
Stadt, Land, Fluss in… Wir sind in Schleswig-Holstein.
Starten soll Stadt, Land, Förderwenn schon, mann. Starten soll das Ganze…
Ist das dein eigentlicher Förderverein?
Starten soll das Ganze nach der nächsten Saison und 2030 fertiggestellt werden. Ganz interessant, das war Mitgliederversammlung bei Kiel und ich trage das jetzt nicht vor, aber der User Care– ich hoffe, ich spreche das richtig aus– der hat das, ich glaube, bekannter Rasenfunk-Forum-User, auch bekannter Discord-User, Grüße gehen raus– der hat das mal ein bisschen zusammengetragen, auch welche Stresspunkte es gab zwischen Fans, zwischen Vereinen, auch rund um diese Stadionbau, was der Hauptsponsor dann auch so wollte. Der hat das da zusammengetragen. Empfehle ich euch einfach mal einen Blick ins Forum, wenn euch das interessiert. Sonst würde ich sagen, wir machen mal so ein bisschen Dampf und wechseln zu Dynamo Dresden, wenn das für dich passt, Marc. Gut, das sieht so kritisch aus. Ich habe schon eben gesagt, Rote Laterne Platz 18, 3 10 Punkte, 24 zu 34 Tore, 3 Siege, 4 Unentschieden, 10 Niederlagen. Zuletzt 3 Niederlagen in Folge, nach 2 Siegen in Folge. Man gewinnt einfach zu wenig Spiele, obwohl man nicht immer so viel unterlegen ist. Aber gerade defensiv ist das leider zum Teil vorgewillt, was da passiert. Ähnliche Probleme, die ich glaube, ich eben schon mal in Bielefeld zum Teil in der Qualität erwähnt habe, aber eben defensiv da um einiges schlechter. Es ist die schlechteste Hinrunde in der Vereinsgeschichte, in der 2. Liga, eben die 2 schwächste Defensive der Liga. Ich glaube, Marc, es ist leider sehr exemplarisch, was in diesem Spiel passiert ist, ehrlich gesagt. Also man kann es wirklich als exemplarisch sehen, diese Dresden, für die Dresdener Saison. Denn ich werfe noch eine Statistik rein. Neunmal hat man in dieser Saison geführt, nur ein Drittel dieser Spiele hat man auch gewonnen. Und eben auch da neuer Sportchef Sören Gontar soll es werden. Man hatte sich vor sechs Wochen von Sportgeschäftsführer Thomas Brendel getrennt und Sören Gontar war zuletzt Geschäftsführer Sport und Finanzen bei Hessen Kassel. Also Marc, ich glaube, wir hatten sehr, sehr viele Leute hatten Dresden als Absteiger. Und man muss leider, leider Prognosen beziehungsweise attestieren nach dieser Halbserie zurecht.
Definitiv. Also ich habe auch noch mal eine Statistik. Kein einziges Spiel zu Null. Es ist zusammen, also sie haben zwar zehn Gegentore weniger als viert kassiert und trotzdem fühlt sich die Defensivleistung ähnlich schlecht an bei Dresden. Es sind immer wieder diese individuellen Fehler, absurd hohe Quote dahingehend. In dem Spiel, wie gesagt, das ist dann Hermann, der aber auch nicht so einen geilen Pass hat. Der hat schon Gegenspieler im Rücken. Das sind einfach so Unachtsamkeiten, die sich durch die Saison seit Beginn ziehen. Wer zu Hause drei Gegentore von Braunstreit bekommt, Holler die Waldfee, der wird es auch einfach schwer haben. Ich habe schon ein Torhüterschreiber erwähnt, minus 4,3 Tore verhindert, also quasi vier Tore mehr bekommen, als er eigentlich hätte sollen. Er kostet Punkte. Da ist natürlich auch die Verletzung von Lennard Grill, der sich zwischenzeitlich vorbeigeschoben hatte, maximal bitter. Der hat ihm, glaube ich, ein besseres Gefühl gegeben. Ich komme immer wieder darauf hinaus, und das passt dann auch zur Saisonprognose, glaube ich, was ich auch schon gesagt habe. Es reicht ihm– es reicht qualitativ einfach nicht. Ich finde, es ist zu– sowohl in der Spitze als auch in der Breite ist dieser Kader nicht gut genug aufgestellt. Defensiv ist es offensichtlich. Auf der Torhüter-Position ist es offensichtlich. Ich mag durchaus die offensiven Spieler Dresdens. Ich finde schon, dass sie da Leute haben, die mal was machen, was man vielleicht nicht so erwartet. Lämmer ist da natürlich zu nennen, beispielsweise. Aber auch– wie heißt der schwedische Kollege? Muss ich hier einmal kurz öffnen. Hier googelt der Chef noch nicht. Da, Nils Fröhling. Nils Fröhling, den finde ich auch. Das ist wirklich ein Motor in der Mannschaft. Dynamo wird sich hier einmal einblenden. Der Luca Herrmann ist jemand, der immer wieder was macht. Dominic Cota kann immer wieder was bewirken. Auch so ein junger Spieler wie Jonas Öhmichen. Sie haben mit Fermee und Taferne eigentlich Stürmer, die zur 2. Liga passen. Ich finde aber, der gesamte hintere Abwehrverbund ist einfach nicht gut. Das werden sie jetzt auch nicht mehr im Winter geregelt bekommen. Ich finde, da sind sie ein Stück weit, wenn es nicht finanziell möglich war, okay. Aber sie sind ein bisschen zu naiv, finde ich, in der Kaderplanung gewesen und haben geglaubt, dass das so funktioniert mit derselben Wucht, wie man sie in der 3. Liga hatte. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich erkenne total an, dass die Mannschaft lebt, dass die ackert. Das sieht man in jedem Spiel. Ich halte von Trainer Stamm einiges, aber er hat zu wenig, mit dem er arbeiten kann. Und Tendenz bleibt dieselbe. Für mich ist Dresden der klarste Absteiger. Man kann den Eifer nicht absprechen, aber das ist auch keine kaputte Truppe oder so was. Im Gegenteil. Aber es reicht einfach nicht. Und die haben zum Rückrundenbeginn Fürth und Magdeburg. Das sind direkt zwei Schicksalsspiele. Klar, wenn sie die gewinnen, dann sind sie mitten in der Verlosung und dann wächst so eine Mannschaft über sich auch mal hinaus. Aber ich glaube nicht so richtig dran. Wie ist es bei dir?
Nee, ich gehe da mit. Also ich glaube, dass man muss halt was sagen, die diese Euphorie, die sie auch hätte mitbringen können, die ist halt, glaube ich, so ein bisschen, dadurch, dass man im Prinzip die Meisterschaft in der dritten Liga verspielt hat, vielleicht da auch so ein bisschen weg, obwohl man natürlich trotzdem sagen muss, man hat es dann damals endlich geschafft. Ich glaube auch weiterhin, dass das intakt ist. Also Thomas Stamm, der hat auf jeden Fall den Rückhalt der Mannschaft. Ich glaube auch von der Geschäftsführung, das wurde auch nochmal betont. Also gerade Christoph Dafferna hat sich nochmal für Thomas Stamm ausgesprochen. Und eben auch er darf man eben nicht vergessen. Es geht immer so ein bisschen unter, wir haben so viele neue Trainer in dieser Liga gehabt in dieser Saison schon, dass man das vielleicht ein bisschen unterschätzt. Aber man muss halt leider einfach sagen, dass es schon gesagt nur Braunschweig gelang es in den letzten 6 Jahren, sich durch die Relegation noch in der Liga zu retten. Das war letzte Saison mit dieser Punkteausbeute nach 17 Spielen. Und es fällt einfach schwer, weil du siehst ihnen einfach dabei zu, wie sie sich quasi selber immer wieder in die Situation bringen. Und das wird dann halt irgendwann einfach schwierig. Ich empfehle sonst nochmal, wenn euch Dresden interessiert, wenn ihr mehr dazu hören wollt, auch analysen, einmal den Schwarz-Gelb-Podcast von Jens Umbreit. Der analysiert ja auch immer ganz gut. Und das habe ich euch auch einmal in den Show Notes verlinkt. Ich würde sagen, mit schnellen Schritten Richtung Winterpause, Marc. Wir gucken auf Nürnberg gegen Hannover. Nürnberg beendet die Hinrunde in der oberen Tabellenhälfte. Benjamin Kellmann bringt die Hannoveraner zwar in Führung. Raphael Lubach gleicht aber kurz vor der Pause aus. Somas sorgt dann kurz nach der Pause für Nürnberger, Ekstase und drei Punkte im Frankenland. Also auch hier ein Team, was im Prinzip am Ende noch das Spiel für sich drehen könnte. Nürnberg, die stehen auf Platz 8, auch 22 Punkte, 19 zu 23 Tore, sechs Siege, vier unentschieden, sieben Niederlagen. Auch über Nürnberg haben wir relativ ausführlich zuletzt immer wieder gesprochen. Die hatten komische Wochen zuletzt. Sieg gegen Bielefeld, Niederlage gegen Magdeburg und entschieden im Franken-Turbi Niederlage gegen Schalke, Sieg gegen Hannover. Da war irgendwie alles dabei. Ich finde auch Folge, dass man jetzt im Zentrum steht, der Liga, und da muss man ja sagen, Marc, nach dem Saisonbeginn und nach dem… Mein Kollege von der Freunde Felix Radfelder hat mal bei Elin Tesic gesagt, er wäre das Gänseblümchen, das menschgewordene Gänseblümchen, weil das so ein bisschen dieses, bleibt er, bleibt er nicht, bleibt er, bleibt er nicht, wird's denn, was wird's denn nicht? Und ich glaube, dann ist das eine per se erstmal gute Nachricht für alle Nürnberger, auch für Miroklose, dass man sich jetzt so weit stabilisiert hat im Zentrum.
Punkt. Ich glaube, das Spiel zeigt, dass Nürnberg in dieser Liga einfach mithalten kann, jedem Gegner auch gefährlich werden kann. Dafür haben sie allerlei Waffen im Kader. Ich bleibe dabei. Klose mag vielleicht nicht der beste Trainer dieser Liga sein, aber er ist definitiv mal ein ordentlicher Trainer. Und ich bleibe dabei. Er hat im Sommer eine absolut undankbare Aufgabe bekommen, als quasi einmal der Kader ausgetauscht wurde und sehr spät mit absolut 2. Liga unerfahrenen Spielern, die ja auch aus allerlei Nationen kamen, fertiggestellt wurde. So etwas braucht Zeit und so was kann auch komplett nach unten, nach hinten losgehen. Da würde ich also eher das Auge auf die sportliche Führung legen, die in meinen Augen das Transferrad so ein bisschen überdreht hat. Klose ist es gelungen, diese junge, sehr neu zusammengestellte Mannschaft durchaus zu stabilisieren. Seit dem sechsten Spieltag hat man nur noch drei Spiele verloren. Das ist, finde ich, erst mal bemerkenswert. Es ist nicht immer der schönste Fußball. Es ist viel Launen auch auf Konter, aber hin und wieder blitzt dann ja durch Justwahn, durch Nubach und Co. auch spielerische Klasse auf. Was Klose sich aber auch nicht backen kann, ist ein guter zweitiger Mittelstürmer. Also diese sehr späte Verpflichtung von Grimaldi zeigt ja schon, dass da was verpennt wurde, weil auch das, denke ich mal, nicht die Wunschlösung war. Man hat Sievers einfach nicht ersetzt bekommen. Klose hat als noch junger Trainer dazugelernt. Er hat zwischenzeitlich dann ja auch das System geändert, das von Fünfer- auf Viererkette gewechselt. Alles ein bisschen konservativer, alles ein bisschen direkter. Nicht mehr nur der Kombinationsfußball. Den er sich vielleicht wünschen würde. Wenn man mal so auf die darunter liegenden Zahlen guckt. Torschüsse Platz 9, Großchancen Platz 9, genaue Pässe Platz 8, Expected Goals zugelassen Platz 5. Das ist alles solide. Das ist alles in Ordnung. Manchmal holen sie ein bisschen mehr aus den Spielen. Sie müssen dieses Spiel gegen Hannover nicht gewinnen. Das sind dann halt auch zwei einfach gespielte Angriffe, die Hannover eigentlich besser verteidigen muss. Aber da werden wir gleich über die 96er reden, weil auch das ist ja etwas, was symbolisch ein bisschen ist. Ich will sagen, Nürnberg wird in dieser Saison keine großen Sprünge mehr machen, weder nach oben noch nach unten. Das ist ein klares Übergangsjahr, um viele Spieler an diese 2. Liga zu gewöhnen. Das ist auch okay so. Ich sage jetzt schon mal, haltet doch mal an dem Miro fest. Der macht das insgesamt jetzt zwei Jahre, finde ich, sehr in Ordnung dafür, was ihm da teilweise auch am Kader gegeben wird. Weil, viel Talent hast du schon gesagt, Eva, ist in der 2. Liga auch nicht immer entscheidend. Du musst die PS auf die Straße bekommen. Und das ist mit so einem Kader, wo Spieler dabei sind, die Deutschland noch nicht mal kennen oder gerade aus der A-Jugend von irgendjemanden verpflichtet werden. Das war ja bei Lubach mehr oder weniger damals auch der Fall. Und jetzt ist er unter Kloße ein annehmbarer 2. Liga-Spieler geworden.
Ja, oder, also...
Das ist okay, erarbeitet. Und da wird was entwickelt. Und das finde ich okay.
Und deswegen, wenn die jetzt am Ende bei Platz 10 oder so rauskommen, total...
Ich würde sogar fast argumentieren, Lubach ist für mich, für die Nürnberger, die Entdeckung der Saison, ehrlich gesagt. Also du merkst sofort, wenn der mitspielt, das hat Michi, glaube ich, auch letztes Mal ganz gut rausgearbeitet, was passiert, wenn Raphael Lubach eben Teil dieses, auch des Spielaufbaus, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, das schafft Klose schon ganz gut. Ich glaube, es ist auch exemplarisch, die erste Halbzeit sprach komplett dagegen, oder zumindest die ersten 44 Minuten, dass man mit Klose verlängern sollte. Die zweite sprach eher dafür. Mehr dazu natürlich auch. Und du kriegst eine Podcast-Empfehlung, und du kommst natürlich an den Cut- Cutter Podcast. Ihr wisst Bescheid. Ich glaube, da generell sowieso der Hinweis, wenn es solche Podcasts gibt, die machen auch alle Hinrundenrückblicks, und ihr wirklich da nochmal eine ganz explizite Einschätzung haben wollt, dann hört da doch gerne rein. Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall immer. Und dann...
Ein Wort noch zu Nürnberg fällt mir gerade noch ein. Die haben halt einfach den zweitgrößten Kader der Liga. Ich würde sogar eigentlich behaupten, dass es der größte ist, weil bei Magdeburg der größte– da sind auch viele Eigengewächse dabei, die halt Profiverträge haben. Bei Nürnberg hast du gefühlt die höchste Profi-Größe des Kaders. Ich hab mal grad mal geguckt, die haben 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 Mittelstürmer.
Das ist quasi Reverse Hoffenheim mit ihren 32 Innenverteidigern.
Und gefühlt keiner funktioniert, das kommt ja noch dazu. Also auch da möchte ich mal eine Lanze für Klose brechen, das zu moderieren, daraus dann einen funktionsfähigen Kader zu basteln. Das schafft auch nicht jeder.
True. Dann lassen wir uns auf Hannover gucken. Platz 5, 29 Punkte, 30 zu 22 Tore, 8 Sege, 5 Unentschieden, 4 Niederlagen. Und man muss einfach wirklich sagen, dieses 2 zu 1 oder 1 zu 2 in Nürnberg, leider ein absolut typisches Hannover-Spiel der letzten Wochen. Nach dem Unentschieden gegen Preußen, nachdem man 2-0 führte und dem 0-0 gegen Bochum, jetzt ist 1-2 nach 1-0 Führung gegen Nürnberg, größtes Problem, Chancenwucher. Laut XG-Tabelle sollte man auf Platz 1 stehen, hat aber leider 6,7 Tore weniger geschossen als geplant. 265 Torschüsse hat man bisher gesamt in dieser Liga abgegeben. Alleine bei dem Spiel, je nach Anbieter, das variiert so zwischen 1,43 und, ich glaube, 2,39 XG. Da frage ich mich auch, was passt das jetzt für eine Anlage hier. Aber eben in dem Spiel, 4 Großchancen, alleine Benjamin Kellmann mit 3 Torschüssen. Und ich glaube, per se, können wir sagen, die Qualität dieses Kaders, die ist weiterhin unbestritten. Die Frage ist, und die würde ich jetzt einfach mal an dich so ein bisschen provokant rübergeben. Hat man zu Beginn der Saison überperformt und von der frühen Zusammenstellung des Kaders profitiert?
Vermutlich schon.
Richtig gemeine Frage auch.
Ja, vermutlich schon. Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Da war auch irgendwie so eine Anfangseuphorie drin. Ich weiß nicht. Also vielleicht ist es ja so, wenn du dann das erste Spiel gewinnst als junge, neu zusammengestellte Truppe, denkst du, ja krass, alles, was uns der Trainer gesagt hat, stimmt. Wir müssen es nur so machen. Und jetzt rasieren wir hier die Liga. Und wenn dann aber die ersten Spiele kommen, wo das eben nicht mehr so funktioniert, fängt das Zweifeln an und du normalisierst dich ein Stück weit. Boah, das hat das Spiel mal wieder gezeigt. 96 kann all diese Dominanz zu selten in Siege ummützen. Du hast die XG-Tabelle schon genannt. Platz 1 bei Expected Goals, Torstösse, Großchance, Ballberührung im glinenischen 16er. Aber eben auch bei vergebenden Großchancen. Sie sind Platz 2 bei Ballbesitz und Passquote. Ohne Frage, 96 spielt den besten Fußball der Liga. Es ist unglaublich konstruktiv und präzise nach vorne. Sie erspielen sich irre viele Chancen. Sie erdrücken den Gegner teilweise regelrecht. Aber es ist eben nicht effizient genug. Und vor allen Dingen defensiv oft nicht. Ja, es ist wie so ein bisschen das schlampige Genie. Sie müssten eigentlich alles können, aber... Aber naja, und dann kommt diese Unkonzentriertheit. Und man fragt sich wirklich, also ich fand das so geil, also ich fand das fast lustig, das erste Tor von Nürnberg, weil das war so stumpf. So, das war langer Ball, Kopfballverlängerung, Lubach ist durch, etwas abgefälschter Schuss, ein großes Tor und das war fast so, also das hatte fast was von einer Demonstration Nürnbergs gegenüber Hannover zu sagen, übrigens Fußball geht auch so einfach.
Ihr müsst einfach nur das Tor treffen, ganz wilder Gedanke.
Ja, es ist wirklich krass, Nürnberg ist oft nicht griffig genug, die sind Platz 17 bei abgefangenen Bällen, Platz 15 bei Tackles, dazu der Torhüter, der wenig rettet. Sie haben 3 Elfmeter schon verursacht. Die agieren defensiv einfach unglücklich, weil oft nicht konzentriert. Das klingt dann immer so nach alte Männer, Effenberg im Doppelpass-Talk, aber es fehlt manchmal dieses Dreckige, dieses Kompromisslose. Dass sie einfach mal die gelbe Karte ziehen, den Gegner. Und wenn das bedeutet, dass man nicht flüssig in den Umschaltmoment kommt, dann ist das so. Es ist... Was bringt einem, also um da so ein Bild aufzumachen, was bringt es, wenn Hannover jedes Spiel ein wunderschönes Gemälde malt, wenn der Gegner einfach einen Stein durch die Leinwand wirft? So, es ist so... Ich mein, in der 2. Liga ist es manchmal stumpf, doch Trumpf. Und es ist natürlich, jeder Fußballliebhaber wünscht sich, dass der Fußball von Tietz Früchte trägt und funktioniert. Und das tut er ja oftmals. Sie stehen ja auf Platz 5, absolut in Reichweite der Aufstiegsplätze. Und mich würde es überhaupt nicht wundern, wenn die in der Rückrunde eine Serie starten und am Ende direkt aufsteigen. Also ich bin null verwundert, weil alles in diesem Kader steckt. Und mittlerweile wäre ich aber eben auch nicht mehr verwundert. Und das hat der Saisonstart eigentlich nicht verheißen lassen, wenn es am Ende eben doch nicht so ist. Und sie wieder über sich selbst stolpern, am Ende 5. werden und man sich fragt, boah, woran hat die gelegt?
Ganz witzig zur Elfmeter-Statistik. Hannover hat bisher 3 Elfmeter gegen sich bekommen, davon ist nur einer reingegangen. Gleichzeitig 5 erhalten, davon sind aber auch nur 3 reingegangen. Also Boris Tomiak 2x, ich werde diesen Elfmeter gegen Bielefeld nicht vergessen, was der da versucht hat und Benni Källmann. Natürlich gegen Bochum zuletzt, dann kriegst du schon die Chance. Klar, auch eine gute Parade von Timo Horn, aber der war auch einfach nicht gut geschossen. Man muss ja auch sagen, das haben wir in der letzten Folge schon mal angesprochen, was passiert mit Markus Mann? Geht er jetzt nach Österreich, tut er es nicht? Was passiert da mit dem TV? Wir freuen uns einfach schon wieder auf die Rückrunde. Da ist Elfpotential drin, da freuen wir uns doch drauf.
Hast du vielleicht einen 96 Podcast, der das in der Tiefe hohendet?
Die Vorwärts-nach-weit-Menschen machen das, glaube ich, ganz gut. Sind aber relativ nah, zum Teil am Verein dran. Zum Teil. Aber da sonst einfach mal reinhören. Da hatten wir auch mal, als er noch dabei war, den Max Bogsall, glaube ich, mal zu Gast. Der hat uns das damals mal versucht, ein wenig zu erklären. Und sonst haben wir natürlich aber einfach our own Tobi Rieger. Der kann uns das dann ja sonst auch persönlich erklären. Den Vorteil haben wir ja quasi ein, weiß ich nicht, Insider-Wissen direkt dabei. Gut, ich würde sagen...
Wir haben ein vorletztes Spiel, ne?
Was?
Jetzt haben wir miteinander geredet. Wir sind beim vorletzten Spiel, wollte ich sagen.
Genau, das vorletzte Spiel. Wir haben einfach euch nochmal einen Unentschieden mitgebracht, weil es so schön ist. Und zwar das zwischen Münster und Elbersberg. Münster, die holen sich noch spät gegen Elbersberg den Ausgleich. Viele, viele, gar nicht mal Last-Minute-entscheidende Tore, aber viele Tore in den letzten Minuten an diesem Spieltag. Batista Maier, der verschießt erst einen fälligen Schraftdus für die Münsteraner. Ebnut Halib, der macht im Gegenzug besser vom Punkt für die Elbersberger. Aber Intien Aminido kann in der 90. Clubs 5 dann den durchaus verdienten Punkt für die Münsteraner sichern. Und da muss man sagen, Platz 12, 20 Punkte, 22 zu 26 Tore, 5 Siege, 5 Unentschieden, 7 Niederlagen. Die sind voll im Soll, die muss man glaube ich sagen auch zur Überraschung vieler unter anderem mir. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das mit Alex Ende so gut funktioniert in der 2. Liga. Und ich muss, man muss einfach sagen, generell da schon mal zweitmeiste Punkte nach Rückstand geholt. Also 13 Mal in Rückstand gewesen, das ist auch die höchste Anzahl, genauso wie bei Kiel und Fürth. Davon aber 10 Punkte geholt. Und da muss man einfach sagen, das ist eben eine Mentalität, das böse Wort, aber eben auch eine Willenskraft, eine Qualität hinten raus, die die Münsterer da mitbringen. Eben auch in diesem Spiel, man war eigentlich auch klar, die bessere Mannschaft muss man eigentlich sagen. Also 2,39 x g zu 1,61 laut Fottmob, glaube ich. Marc, lass uns zuerst eben auf die Münsterer gucken. Das ist schon beeindruckend, was Alex Ende da gemacht hat.
Ende gut, alles gut. Ja, es ist die letzte Stunde, Eva. Du musst jetzt nochmal durch. Nein, jetzt im Ernst, ich habe ja tatsächlich große Hoffnungen. Ich habe tatsächlich nochmal in unsere 2. Liga-Prognose reingehört, weil ich nicht mehr ganz genau wusste, wie mein Take zu Münster war. Da muss ich mir auf die Schulter klopfen, da war das so positiv. Nee, aber im Ernst, ich habe irgendwie dran geglaubt, dass das funktionieren kann, weil mich also nicht nur durch die Verpflichtung von Ende, sondern auch was im Kader passiert ist. Das war für mich so zweigeteilt, weil ich finde, dass Münster einer der besten Transferperioden der 2. Liga hatte. Und dadurch ja sogar es gelang, schmerzhafte Ausfälle zu kompensieren. Also Antonio Tickvich verletzt sich in den ersten Minuten, die er für Münster spielt, schwer. Marvin Schulz hat sich, glaube ich, das Außenband gerissen. Simon Scherder, der für die Truppe wichtig ist mit seiner Erfahrung, hat einen Kreuzbandriss. Malik Badmaz hat einen Kreuzbandriss. Also da sind viele Spieler, die durchaus wichtig sein könnten, auch lange raus. Aber man redet gar nicht so viel darüber, weil die Truppe insgesamt funktioniert. Und das ist schon beeindruckend. Ich finde, Münze hat sich jetzt auch gegen Elbersberg dafür ganz spät belohnt, dass sie einfach einen mutigen Fußball spielen wollen. Ja, es ist ein bisschen konservativer geworden, finde ich, als noch zu Saisonbeginn, wo sie ja radikal gefühlt dieses fast schon Tiki-Taka-Eske gespielt haben. Das ist ein bisschen weniger geworden, ein bisschen vertikaler, ein bisschen direkter, ein bisschen Zweitliga-typischer. Aber sie sind ja immer noch voll bei sich. Sie haben z.B. immer noch den höchsten Ballbesitz der Liga durchschnittlich und wollen dieses mutige, flache Spiel. Nicht ohne Grund hat sich, glaube ich, auch Oliver Partista-Meyer auch zu einem absoluten Unterschiedsspieler entwickelt. Der steht bei acht Scorern dieser Saison.
Ich habe nur gedacht, Perfect Match zum Allesende.
Klar, den kenne ich glaube ich auch. Deswegen finde ich es wirklich beeindruckend, was da gerade für eine Arbeit geleistet wird, sich so mutig zu zeigen. Nach einem Jahr nach dem Aufstieg direkt zu sagen, und jetzt spielen wir nicht mehr nur, wir wollen die Klasse halten, Fußball, sondern wir entwickeln etwas mit Vision. Das finde ich erst mal mutig. Das sieht man nicht so oft. Das haben wir auch schon oft bei Braunschweig und Co. kritisiert, dass man so denkt, ja, und was wollt ihr über den Klassehalt hinaus. So. Das weiß man jetzt bei Münster sehr klar. Da läuft sicherlich noch nicht alles rund, ist teilweise auch mit individueller Qualität zu erklären. Trotzdem ist die Wahrheit, sie stehen nur drei Punkte vor Platz 16. Das kann sich auch ganz schnell natürlich drehen. Aber auch, wie du gesagt hast, wie oft sie nach Rückständen noch zurückgekommen sind, zeigt ja, die Truppe hat Wille. Und ich glaube, dass Münster am Ende relativ souverän in der Klasse bleiben kann. Und das wäre für den Verein, der vor kurzem noch Regionalliga gespielt hat, ein riesiger Erfolg.
Ja, und sicherlich auch mit dem Stadionbau im Hintergrund. Man muss eben auch sagen, hochintensive– ich glaube, das könnte auch ein Grund sein, warum es zum Ende hin vielleicht zum Teil nicht mehr so der Hurra-Fußball war, den man am Anfang der Saison hatte. Also hochintensive Spiele. Sie haben die meisten Zweikämpfe der Liga gewonnen, aber eben auch die meisten Fouls am Gegner. 235 sind das, haben auch die zweitmeisten Karten der Liga nach Bochum. Aber eben auch, und das ist der größte Unterschied zur letzten Saison, man hat die zweithöchste Passquote der Liga. Die zweithöchste Passquote. Und eben auch Ballbesitz auf Nummer 3, obwohl man da echt immer, also ich finde gerade in der zweiten Liga, wo sich das alles irgendwie zwischen 53 Prozent abwärts einpegelt, oder 57 sind es, glaube ich, ist das immer so ein bisschen, ja ehrlich gesagt, für mich immer am Ende des Tages doch so eine leichte Quatsch-Statistik, weil man immer wieder sieht, Ballbesitz bedeutet nicht automatisch, dass du gut darin bist, ein Spiel zu demonieren, zu dominieren, kontrollieren, demonieren, wo kommen die Dämonen her, man weiß es nicht. Aber eben dieses generell, du siehst eben auch bei Preußen, wie bei vielen Vereinen, die mit so einer klassischen Viererkette spielen, wir haben es bei Bochum eben mal angesprochen, dieses, wenn du da eigentlich diese Viererkette mit raute, das hat ihre Vorteile, gibt eben aber auch einfach ihre Nachteile, wenn du einen tiefen Block bespielen musst, etc. Aber trotzdem einfach grundsolide Leistung. Ich glaube von Preußenfans wird immer gesagt, etablierter Zweitligist. Soweit würde ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht gehen. Dazu gehört für mich noch ein bisschen mehr dazu, ehrlich gesagt, no disrespect. Aber genau, da würde ich per se sagen, sie sind auf einem sehr guten Weg auf jeden Fall. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass du immer wieder in den Rückstand gerätst, das musst du glaube ich einfach mal abstellen, ehrlich gesagt. Weil irgendwann prognostiziere ich einfach mal, weil dieser Fußballspiel oder Stil auch so intensiv ist, ist halt irgendwann die Frage, ob es da die beliebte Regression zur Mitte gibt. Also dass du halt irgendwann nicht mehr schaffst, intensitätsmäßig das immer wieder rauszuholen, wenn du immer wieder in den Rückstand gerätst. Aber das ist natürlich wirklich so Glaskugeldenken. Und auch da habe ich eine Empfehlung, Marc. Und zwar das Preußen-Journal.
Ja, auf, echt.
Das ist kein Podcast, aber ein Blog. Also wer lieber lesen möchte als hören, dem sei das empfohlen von Carsten Schulte ist das. Und da könnt ihr dann eben schriftlich noch mal nachlesen, was passiert eben auch rund um den Stadionbau und Co. Dann kommen wir noch auf Elbersberg. Da ist vielleicht per se war kurz die Stimmung ein bisschen getrübt, dass man eben nicht die drei Punkte holt, aber muss trotzdem sagen Platz 2. 34 Punkte, 31 zu 15 Tore, 10 Siege, 4 Unentschieden, 3 Niederlage. Es ist eine wahnsinnig gute Runde, die Elbersberg spielt. Es ist die beste Offensive der Liga. Mit Eppenthalib hat man den besten Stürmer der Liga in seinen eigenen Reihen. Noch könnte man sagen, sie kassieren weniger Tore als statistisch berechnet. Das gehört dazu. Also 15 vs. 20,5 sagt man. Aber man muss einfach sagen, ich bringe jetzt schon einfach mal die Tipps von uns rein. Also lass mich gucken. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 von uns hatten Elbersberg als Absteiger drin. Und da muss man sagen, die haben sich das durchgelesen und haben gesagt, ja, dann tschüss. Und dann muss man einfach sagen, Marc, also wir haben es hier schon immer wieder betont. Aber Vincent Wagner und Elbersberg, was die in dieser 2. Liga spielen, es ist schon ganz gut, um es mal ausmissschädlich auszudrücken.
Nils Odeburg, the man, wirklich. Das ist unfassbar, was der für eine Arbeit leistet. Es ist unfassbar. Da gehen im Sommer Damar, Aslani, Elias Baum und Horst Steffen. Und es ist egal. So, weil dann holen die einfach einen Yunus Abnuthalib vom FC Gießen. FC Gießen. 50.000 Euro haben die für den gezahlt. Und jetzt ist zu lesen, dass Frankfurt und Wolfsburg da irgendwie 5 bis 6 Millionen bereit sind zu zahlen. Und der darf wahrscheinlich sogar trotzdem dann bis Saisonende noch in Elbersberg spielen. Der hat sich auch, glaube ich, festgelegt, dass er gesagt hat, im Winter würden wir jetzt eigentlich nicht gehen wollen. Das heißt, da sichert sich wahrscheinlich ein Verein dann den einfach schon mal. 12 Tore in 17 Spielen. Und dazu kommen ja auch andere Spieler. Da darf das ja nicht nur darauf beziehen. Also ich finde, dass Lukas Poreba hat sich da echt festgespielt. Ein Conté auf der... Also Bamba Sarkony habe ich irgendwie immer nur auf seine Schnelligkeit reduziert, aber der zeigt auf der 10, dass der richtig kicken kann. Der funktioniert super gut. Jambra war als Baumersatz... Das ist so was Grundsätzliches, wie nicht glänzvoll ist, aber es funktioniert dahinter. Dann natürlich auch so Spieler wie Malanga oder Otto Stange, die oftmals eher von der Bank kommen, aber dann auch noch einen Einfluss haben. Da fehlen mir echt, da gehen einem die Superlative wirklich aus, was da für Arbeit geleistet wird. Vincent Wagner sofort in der 2. Liga angekommen, akklimatisiert, ein super Kommunikator, aber auch ein fantastischer Taktiker. Entwicklender, junger Spieler weiter haben aber auch diese Spieler, die ihm einfach einen Halt geben. Also ein Christoph, der mittlerweile einfach österreichischer Nationaltorhüter ist. Ein Zimmercheat, über den gefühlt niemand redet, weil der einfach irgendwie immer da ist. Aber Tom Zimmercheat ist halt auch super für die 2. Liga. Lejean Kour und Pink hat in der Innenverteidigung. Das ist das Herzstück der Defensive. Also ich finde es wirklich irre. Ich krieche in den Rauch und in den Staub dafür, was ich da am Anfang der Saison getippt habe. Aber man konnte ja nicht ahnen, was die da wieder gekocht haben im Sommer. Dann verlängert Nils Ulleburg sogar, sagt, das ist hier langfristig mein Ding. Mir macht das Spaß. Ich kann verstehen, wieso. Und das ist alles schon absurd. Und sie stehen ja auch verdientermaßen da. Also wenn man da auf die XG-Tabelle guckt, ja, also eigentlich wären sie Platz 3. Okay, so. Es ist ja nun wirklich nun nicht, dass das irgendwie durch Zufall passiert ist. Und mir fehlt auch die Fantasie, warum das jetzt in der Winterpause irgendwie oder andersrum in der Rückrunde nach der Winterpause einbrechen sollte, weil diese Mannschaft gefühlt ja nur weiter zusammenwachsen kann. Die ist ja sogar relativ neu. Und diese Spieler wie Conte und Koh, ich habe sie genannt, die sind ja noch jung. Otto Stange ist, ich glaube, immer noch 18. Ja, das ist schon irre. Und dementsprechend, ja, die werden bis zum Ende um den Aufstieg mitspielen. Und das ist eine absolute Sensation, dieser Satz.
Ja, man muss ja sogar sagen, was vielleicht etwas Positives, etwas berghatte schon, diese leichte Schwächephase einmal. Ende Oktober bis Anfang November könnte man sagen, bzw. Ende Oktober, Anfang November, also man hatte diese Niederlagen gegen Hertha und Bielefeld, wo man irgendwie nicht so ganz wusste, was da jetzt irgendwie gerade nicht passt, hat sich da eben auch wieder rausgezogen. Also Schwächephase in großen Anführungszeichen, da spricht auch wieder so ein bisschen Ben, was eben auch die Qualität oben in der Liga betrifft, dass so richtig niemand denen den Rang ablaufen konnte, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das ist schon, also diese Grundqualität, wir haben das eben auch schon mal bei Darmstadt und so gesagt, die dieses Team einfach mitbringt, das ist einfach sehr bemerkenswert. Gut, ich würde auch eben sagen, du hast jetzt in dem Spiel so ein bisschen gemerkt, du gehst ein bisschen glücklich eben durch diese Elfmeter-Einführung, hast aber ehrlich gesagt sonst über 90 Minuten bist du die schlechtere Mannschaft. Ich glaube, da würde mir wenig Elversberger widersprechen. Also das wäre für Münzer schon irgendwie doppelt bitter gewesen, wenn man das verliert, aber du hast es eben auch gesagt. Am Ende wäre das auch zu, ich würde mal sagen, 99,9 Prozent auf den Nacken von Christoph gegangen, weil der einfach so viele Bälle gehalten hat und einfach so eine Qualität auch auf der Linie hat. Das ist schon bemerkenswert. Ich glaube, er hält ja auch den Elfmeter von zu Beginn von Batista Mayer. Also von daher sehr bemerkenswert und wie gesagt auch einfach, bei denen weißt du einfach nichts. Du hast neun Tore nach Standards, du hast fünf nach Kontern, du hast 15 auf dem offenen Spiel heraus. Also es gibt auch gar nicht so dieses eine, wo du sagst, ach lass das die mal nicht machen. Das ist einfach so. Ist egal, können die alles. Und das ist schon diese Vielseitigkeit, die wir ja wiederum zum Beispiel bei Hertha kritisiert haben, dass sie das eben auch manchmal nicht haben, da vielleicht auch so vielseitig zu sein. Aber da muss man einfach sagen, sehr und also spielen auch durchaus dann, wie der Ball da zum Teil zirkuliert, das kannst du dir schon echt gut an.
Das ist einfach feiner Fußball.
Wie schaffe ich jetzt den Übergang von feiner Fußball zu Braunschweig gegen Schalke? Herbstmeister Schalke 04 muss zum Abschluss des Jahres seine vierte Saisonniederlage hinnehmen. In Braunschweig steht es nach 45 Minuten 0 zu 0. In der zweiten Halbzeit Song Aydin und Sane. Ausgerechnet möchte man sagen, solche Geschichten schreibt ausschließlich nur der Fußball. Für die Braunschweiger Führung El Fahousis Treffer in der 88. Minute kann den Braunschweigersieg nicht mehr verhindern. Braunschweig, die stehen, auch ich würde schon sagen, ein bisschen überraschend auf Platz 13. 20 Punkte, 20 zu 29 Tore, 6 Siege, 2 unentschiedenen, 9 Niederlagen. Ganz, ganz wichtiger Sieg für die Braunschweiger zu Hause. Es war erst der dritte Halbsieg für die Löwen. Zuletzt zeigt die Formkurve deutlich nach oben. 3 Sieger, 1 unentschiedenen und 1 Niederlage in den letzten 5 Spielen. Das sind richtig, richtig wichtige Punkte gewesen. Auch Marc, weil man ja sagen muss, so zwischendurch, Rumorte ist durchaus um Heiner Backhaus.
Total. Und man wird jetzt dafür belohnt, an ihm festgehalten zu haben. Ist relativ einfach. Und auch dieses, also das gilt ja oft so als Notlüge oder als Voranschieben oder als Ausrede im Sinne von, wir haben ja so viele Verletzten und Gesperrte. Aber da muss man mal sagen, das hat bei Braunschweig halt ein Wahrheitsgehalt gehabt. Und seitdem diese Spieler alle so einmählich zurückkehren, und Lino Tempelmann ist ja noch gar nicht wieder da, zum Beispiel als wichtiger Spieler, und manchmal am Stück vielleicht mit einer Dreierkette oder so spielen kann, seitdem funktioniert es, seitdem hat es es stabilisiert. Und seitdem erkennt man auch mehr einen Plan nach vorne. Das war ja vielleicht das größte Problem, finde ich, zwischenzeitlich, dass man wirklich dachte, wie wollt ihr denn Tore schießen? Das war wirklich zwischenzeitlich echt übel. Ich erinnere mich an eine Folge mit Anna Lautenbach. Kann ich dir das auch nicht beantworten. Das gefühlt nicht so lange her. Man hat zehn Punkte aus den letzten vier Spielen geholt, genauso wie Magdeburg zum Beispiel. Und es ist einfach verdientermaßen jetzt schon, finde ich, da, wo man steht. Ja, das Spiel, das war über weite Strecken zäh. Das ist aber erstmal kein Problem für die Mannschaft, die gegen den Herbstmeister spielt. Und man muss ja auch sagen, wenn es gefährlich wurde im Spiel, dann war es eigentlich in der Regel Braunschweig. Zumindest bis dann, dass 2 zu 0 fiel und Schalke nochmal musste. Belbel hatte eine Chance zum 1 zu 0 relativ früh. Man war insgesamt die zwingendere Mannschaft, das Tor von Aydin ist verdient, Schalke lief meist hinterher. Bitter, sehr bitter ist die Verletzung von Comté, der den riesige Probleme bereitet hat, generell wichtig für die Offensive ist. Da muss man mal abwarten, wie lange der raus ist, aber morgen wird er wahrscheinlich nicht auf dem Platz stehen und dementsprechend ist das erstmal eklig. Ansonsten ist man immer wieder durch Konter, die man gut ausspielt, flach ausspielt, sehr gefährlich. Man hat viel Tempo über Jardimski, über Konter, über dann später Zané und Co. Auch die Außenbahn-Spieler haben da, also diese Schienenspieler haben da durchaus Offensivdrang. Das 2 zu 0 finde ich ist auch ein super, also es ist ein gut herausgespielter Umschaltmoment. So Zané einmal kurz verlagert, dann getroffen. Da sieht man auch, wenn der ist ja auch ein junger Spieler, der wächst gerade auch an seinen Aufgaben, habe ich ein bisschen das Gefühl. Ja und Schalke, also dementsprechend, um vielleicht im Braunschweig-Part abzuschließen, die kriegen gerade die Kurve. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Mannschaft und Trainer da eine gemeinsame Idee verfolgen. Und das kann alles immer noch einreißen, definitiv. Also braucht sich keiner wundern, wenn Braunschweig am Ende doch unten drin steht. Aber das ist jetzt nicht mehr so klar, finde ich. Und dementsprechend sind die mitten drin im Kampf um den Klassenerhalt. Und das ist schon mal eine positive Nachricht dafür, wie es zwischenzeitlich aussah.
Ja, ich muss vor allem auch sagen, Braunschweig hat es abgestellt. Es tut mir leid, ich finde keine anderen Worte dafür, so extrem dumme Platzverweise zu bekommen. Sie spinnen Platzverweise in dieser Saison. Davon 5 direkt rote, 2 gelb-rote Karten. Das war ja inzwischen wirklich der Running-Gag der Saison, dass du irgendwie wusstest, ah ja, Braunschweig ist hinunterzahlen. Mensch, das ist ja komisch, so nach dem Motto. Aber da hat man sich eben auch gefangen, was natürlich ehrlich gesagt auch viel mit Positionierung zu tun hat. Vielleicht hat einer Backhaus, der ja immer so von der Emotionalität kommt, vielleicht auch vielleicht ein, zwei Schienen wieder runtergefahren. Muss man ja sagen. Ich meine, die Hauptsache ist, und ich glaube, da sind wir uns bewusst, wir können, glaube ich, vieles akzeptieren in dieser ersten Saison unter Backhaus. Also würde ich jetzt von außen sagen, für mich wird halt wirklich das Wichtige, was in der nächsten Saison passiert. Weil, das muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen, es gibt zu viele Ansätze jetzt bei Braunschweig, als dass ich sage, und mit Backhaus bist du da nächste Saison wieder im Abstiegskampf. Weil wir haben, du hast es eben schon mal gesagt, Marc, wir fragen vor allem bei Vereinen wie Braunschweig, immer so, ja, aber ihr könnt doch nicht, euer Ziel kann doch nicht 6 Jahre lang in der 2. Liga sein, wir holen am letzten Spieltag den Klassenhalt irgendwie, oder durch die Relegation. Und ich glaube, da muss man auch sagen, dafür ist ja schon Potenzial da, dass du es eben anders machst, und das wäre eben schon mal vorausgegriffen. Meine große Frage, ich bin vollkommen fein, glaube ich, und ich glaube, das sind auch viele Braunschweiger, wenn du vielleicht ausnahmsweise mal in dieser Saison drei Spieltage vor Schluss sagen kannst, alles klar, macht ihr mal, wir machen uns jetzt unser Spaßgetränk auf und gucken euch dabei zu, was ihr veranstaltet an den letzten Spieltagen. Aber ich muss einfach sagen, ich erwarte, vielleicht ist das zu hoch gerechnet, aber ich erwarte von Braunschweig irgendwann mal, wenn man sagt, nach der Analyse im Sommer, und ich weiß, das dauert noch ein bisschen, okay, Backhaus ist richtig und für uns und das passt und Spieler sagen, das passt, dann erwarte ich aber auch irgendwann mal so einen Step drüber. Weil dafür war mir das in dieser Saison trotzdem, wir haben es eben auch gearbeitet, zu sehr wieder in diese alte Abstiegskampfleihe reingerutscht mit Spielen, wo du einfach sagen musst, nee, sorry. Also das ist nicht, wie du gerade gegen die Gegner bestehen kannst. Und wie gesagt, dieser Sieg gegen, du hast es auch gemerkt, ich finde, im Stadion an Heiner Backhaus, da ist ganz, ganz viel rausgebrochen. Aber ich muss trotzdem einfach sagen, da habe ich so ein bisschen, also die Expectations, die gehen ein bisschen hoch, einfach auch alleine, wie man eben Heiner Backhaus vorgestellt hat.
Das ist richtig, was ich finde, wo man schon eine Vision ein bisschen erkennen kann, ist, dass sie ja den Kader stark verjüngt haben. Also man mit Aydin ist 23, Sidizane ist 22. So Leute wie Robin Häusern sind auch mal im besten Fußballeralter. Vorher hatte man viele über 30, wo man jetzt immer mehr aussortiert. Patrik Nkroa in der Innenverteidigung ist auch erst 26. Da sehe ich zumindest, dass man mal ein bisschen perspektivischer handelt, als wir holen uns jetzt irgendwie Typ Ermin Bigacic. Und das wird schon für ein, zwei Jahre noch gut gehen, sondern mit dem wollen wir vielleicht mal 3 Jahre eine Mannschaft aufbauen. Das wäre mal ganz nett. Und wenn sie gehen, dann vielleicht mal für ein bisschen Geld, ähnlich wie jetzt im Sommer so ein Ryan Philipp. Du brauchst halt mal diese Transfers. Der hat ja mal zweieinhalb Millionen eingebracht. Wann hat das Braunschweig zuletzt gehabt? Und da sehe ich zumindest ein bisschen Vision. Ja, aber dann sind wir eigentlich auch bei Schleife schon, oder? Würdest du noch was sagen?
Ich würde einfach nur noch einmal mit Eiding auch hervorheben. Auch einfach absolut, auch welche Tore er erzielt, finde ich sehr, sehr spannend. Also der ist der Mann für die schönen Dinger, aber eben neben vier Toren, neben auch sieben Assists, also Dreh- und Angelpunkt, da vorne drin, das ist einfach die perfekte Überleitung zum FC Schalke. Oder nicht? Ein Ex-Schalker zu Schalke, last but not least.
Man hätte gefühlt das mit jedem aus dem Braunschalke-Arkader machen können, weil die einfach Schalke, die sind ja so eine Zweitvertretung von Schalke mehr oder weniger, das ist ja völlig wahnsinnig. Hätte man mit allen machen können, ja, Schalke. Klar, kleiner Dämpfer jetzt, aber am Ende steht da trotzdem, nach 17 Spielen stehen da 37 Punkte. Die beste Abwehr der Liga. Man steht jetzt schon 4 Punkte vor Rang 3. Das ist, auch da muss man sich so ein bisschen wie bei Elbersberg die Augen reiben. Und man, also das war lange eine nicht vorstellbare Dimension, dass Schalke dort stehen würde. Und das hat sich natürlich mit der Zeit, nimmt man das immer mehr an und es wird immer normaler, aber ist es eigentlich nicht. Auch hier wurde schon oft lange über Schalke geredet. Am Ende ist es halt wirklich die Miron-Muzlitsch-Magie, der diesen Kader irgendwie wiederbelebt hat. Mit Frank Baumann ist da jemand gekommen, der seinen Job versteht und der, wie ich finde, auch wirklich sehr gute Transfers getätigt hat. Und was ich vorhin vielleicht, da spannt sich so ein bisschen der Bogen zu Hertha. Bei Hertha habe ich das Gefühl, wie gesagt, das ist so ein Kader, der kann von allem ein bisschen was. Und dadurch entsteht dann auch so ein Fußball, der nicht ganz klar die klare Identität hat. Schalke hat wirklich im Sommer, die haben sogar Ablöse für den Muzlic bezahlt und sind aber auch den zweiten Schritt gegangen und gesagt, weißt du was, wenn wir das machen, machen wir es ganz. Und wir kaufen jetzt auch einen Muzlic-Kader zusammen. Und dann kommen halt so Spieler wie Timo Becker, wie Nikola Kartic, wie Kurucai in der Innenverteidigung. Aber auch ein Elfer Uzi im Mittelfeld, ein Finn Poran im Mittelfeld, Jungs, die richtig viel laufen können. Und vielleicht sagt man da sogar Brian Lasme, weißt du was, wenn du bleibst, ist das auch okay. Weil vielleicht kannst du nur, kannst du nur, nee, also weißt du, den hätte man ja wahrscheinlich schon irgendwie aus Gelsenkirchen rauskarren können. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das ein Spieler ist mit seinem Tempo, mit seiner Physis, der auch zum Fußball von Muzic passt. Und wo der vielleicht im Sommer gesagt hat, naja, warte mal. Naja, warte mal. Und das ist schon irre. Da greift natürlich irgendwann alles ineinander. Die Spieler haben das komplett eingesogen. Diese Energie, diese Intensität, diesen Stil, den man haben will, dazu werden junge Spieler gefördert. Allen voran, finde ich, muss man Davide Libecker nennen, auf der linken Schiene, der da jetzt einfach Stammspieler ist. Und keiner muss das mehr hinterfragen, weil es halt funktioniert. Aber auch andere Spieler haben es hier vorher getan. Zum Beispiel hat sich ja Mertzschan Ayhan in der Endverteidigung festgespielt. Wir erleben den zweiten Frühling von Loris Karius. Was für eine Geschichte. Und das ist eine Mannschaft, die intakt ist. Das ist eine Mannschaft mit klaren Führungsspielern, die einen klaren Stil fährt, der wirklich nicht schön ist. Da brauchen wir nach wie vor nicht drüber reden. Ja, er hat so ein paar Facetten dazu gewonnen, finde ich. Manchmal im Spiel, aber jetzt beispielsweise gegen Braunschweig, das war spielerisch einfach... Das war wiederum quasi eines Herbstmeisters nicht würdig, wenn man das so formulieren möchte. Ja, naja. Also es war wirklich, finde ich, nach vorne sehr dünn. Irgendwann hat man Druck entwickelt, aber halt zu spät. Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das wird reichen. Ich glaube, wir werden Schalke 04 im Sommer als Erstigisten begrüßen dürfen. Und das ist absolut irre, das zu sagen, wo die Reise dann hingeht, das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber das ist schon bemerkenswert. Findest du noch Worte zu...
Ich möchte dich einfach fragen, ob du noch auf dem Schirm hast, wie viele von uns Schalke in den Top 3 hatten. Richtig.
Niemand?
Keine einzige Person hatte Schalke in den Top 3.
In keiner Welt. Es ist wirklich so krass, hätte man das gedacht.
Ich glaube, wir waren alle wirklich auch sehr negativ belastet, irgendwie von Schalke letzte Saison. Ich habe hier... lasst mich nochmal kurz gucken. Jetzt ist hier dieser Threatwreck. Ich raste aus. Was eben... So, hier. Wie viele Schalke eben als Aufsteiger hatten, das sind 23%. 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 Leute hatten ihn getippt. Respekt. Ich muss sagen, wir hatten bei einer Person von uns war sogar Schalke im Abstiegsbereich. Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob irgendjemand... Ja, 5% haben das auch bei Schalke sogar als Absteiger getippt. Also, man muss einfach sagen, Miron Muslić, es ist schon bemerkenswert und man muss auch wirklich einfach sagen, du hast es eben schon gesagt, das Gesamtpaket Schalke 04, es passt endlich. Muss man einfach sagen. Marc, wärst du fein damit, wenn wir dann diese Spiele, diese 18 Vereine an der Stelle abschließen? Ich glaube, wir haben... Na gut. Bevor ich meinen Abbinder mache, überlasse ich dir die quasi letzten Worte. Was möchtest du gerne noch sagen?
Was möchte ich noch sagen? Ich möchte natürlich ein wunderbares Weihnachtsfest und einen wunderbaren Rutsch wünschen. Das ist vollkommen klar. Ich möchte aber auch sagen, dass mir diese Hinrunde in dem neuen Format sehr, sehr gut gefallen hat. Das hat richtig großen Spaß gemacht. Alle unsere Allstars haben sich ihren Namen definitiv verdient. Das ist immer richtig schön. Man weiß absolut, woran man ist. Dir überreiche ich digital natürlich auch Blumen. Du hast mich das eine oder andere Mal am Anfang auch technisch noch ein bisschen gerettet. Das weiß ich. Das gehört aber dazu. Wir sind auch ein gutes Team. Das macht alles großen Spaß. Es war jetzt auch ein schöner Jahresabschluss. Ansonsten gehabt euch wohl. Bis kommendes Jahr. Dann gucken wir mal, wer am Ende tatsächlich oben wie unten das Rennen macht. Es bleibt wie gewohnt absurd spannend.
Da würde ich fast mitgehen. Hinterlasst doch gerne auch im Forum, im Input-Thread eure Tipps und Wünsche zur Rückrunde. Den verlinke ich euch auch nochmal. Und weil Weihnachten, Feste und Winter nicht für alle Menschen eine angenehme Zeit ist, wir verlinken euch noch die Nummer der Telefonsoil-Sorge, die für euch da ist, falls ihr sie braucht. Und damit, wir hören uns im neuen Jahr wieder. Macht's gut, tschüss! Tschüss! Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.